[Musique]
Anne Lorichel, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Donc Kichel, j'ai fondé Global Sovereign
Advisory en janvier 2019. C'est une
entreprise à mission qui conseille des
États et qui travaille pour des chefs
d'État. Et ultimement, notre but c'est
de travailler pour les peuples. Dans
notre mission, ce qui est très important
pour nous, c'est de d'apprendre et de
faire apprendre aux gens et de les
rendre des meilleurs citoyens. Donc
c'est c'est ce qu'on a vraiment chevillé
au corps. Et donc là maintenant c'est 30
collaborateurs donc on a grossi
rapidement dans un esprit start-up dont
je suis dont je suis très fière et on
conseille une vingtaine de pays dans le
monde. Donc je trouve que ça nous permet
en tout cas ça nous rend riche de cette
expérience là puisque c'est des pays
évidemment partout dans le monde qui ont
des situations extrêmement différentes
et on essaie d'être à leur côté le plus
possible dans des situations qui sont
évidemment pas toujours simples comme ce
qu'on a pu vivre au cours des derniers
mois. Vous faisiez quoi avant ?
Alors avant j'ai fait 20 ans en banque
d'affaires et donc là avec des parcours
qui étaient un peu différents, j'ai
commencé chez LAN Brothers aux
États-Unis et puis à Londres.
Personne n'est parfait.
Mais c'était une expérience extrêmement
intéressante parce qu'en fait j'ai vécu
la faillite de LMAN Brothers au moment
où ça s'est passé hein. J'étais chez
Lman. Alors, j'étais en France à ce
moment-là, donc c'était une situation
qui était enfin qui marque évidemment
une vie, hein, et pas parce que pour les
répercussion que ça a pu avoir dans le
monde, mais aussi il y a toujours la
grande histoire, il y a la petite
histoire. Et dans la petite histoire,
c'était le fait que ce fameux weekend
avant le le 15, le lundi 15,
comme d'habitude.
Oui. On nous on nous disait "The
situation is fluid et on nous expliquait
que tout allait bien alors qu'on savait
le samedi que toutes les autres banques
avaient coupé toutes les lignes avec
avec les manes et c'est vers 2 3h du
matin entre dans la nuit du dimanche à
lundi que les gens ont commencé à
communiquer avec nous et quand je dis
avec nous parce que c'était les les gens
qui étaient à chaque fois désignés dans
les bureaux et c'était une situation
complètement complètement paradoxale
parce parce qu'en fait on le on savait
que la banque n'allait pas bien. On
voyait bien que le cours de l'action
évidemment s'était effondré. On était
censé être des banquier quand même donc
comprendre un peu ce qui se passait et
en même temps on était et tellement dans
nos dossiers et tellement dans des oui
dans dans l'actualité de ce qui était
notre métier que quelque part c'est on
était un peu aussi en déni nous-même de
enfin le truc nous est tombé dessus
vraiment littéralement. Et ces heures
elles ont été fortes. Pourquoi ? parce
qu'à chaque fois chacun réagit de
manière différente. Nous à Paris, il y
avait un truc très simple qui s'était
passé. On était la filiale des
États-Unis directement, ce qui était pas
le cas de de toutes les de toutes les
branches de l'MAN. Et en fait, ça veut
dire qu'on avait fait notre cash pooling
le vendredi.
Traduire pour la communauté ou ceux qui
ne sont pas encore initiés au cash
pouling,
ça ça voulait dire qu'on avait remonté
toute notre trésorerie le vendredi soir
à New York. Donc concrètement, on avait
pas grand-chose, disons ça comme ça, le
lundi matin. Or à l'époque, enfin
c'était la tradition de de l'emmane et
de certaines banques anglo-saxonne, les
salaires étaient payés le 21. Donc la
question était évidemment pas nos
salaires, parf je crois que c'était
absolument ridicule. C'était le salaire
des secrétaires de ceux qui avaient des
empreintes, enfin juste la vraie vie en
fait. Et donc ce qui était assez
intéressant et c'est aussi pour ça que
ça m'a marqué, c'était de voir les
réactions des uns des autres, comment
les gens se positionnaient par rapport à
cette crise. Il y a ceux évidemment qui
ont des comportements plus égoïstes, on
va dire ça comme ça, mais dans la
majeure partie des cas, c'était c'était
plus l'autre qui était qui était une
préoccupation. Et je me souviens très
bien et distinctement qu'entre dans ces
heures du matin, les gens sont répartis
les tâches et moi j'avais enfin trois
tâches. J'étais sur des dossiers qui
étaient très actifs à ce moment-là et
donc bah il fallait évidemment
communiquer avec le client puis aussi
voir très concrètement ce qu'on continue
à faire parce qu'il y avait des
réunions, enfin il y avait il y avait la
vraie vie du banquier. Il y avait le
sujet de regarder ce qu'on faisait
évidemment pour les salaires pour le
pour le 21 et évidemment ce qu'il avait
besoin de se cotiser enfin comment ça se
passait concrètement. Et puis il y avait
aussi le sujet de dire ben on sait pas
ce que c'est que la faillite. On savait
pas nous vraiment enfin matériellement
on savait pas. Il y avait même des gens
qui disaient "Mais est-ce que ça veut
dire que vous allez plus avoir
d'électricité ? Enfin moi j'ai eu des
coups de fil comme ça." Ce qui n'a aucun
sens. Et c'est juste pour dire combien
ça avait tétanisé les gens. Et
évidemment, c'était donc de regarder
est-ce qu'il y a besoin de replacer nos
jeunes, nos équipes, ce qui était quand
même une des premières préoccupations
puisque on voyait bien que quelque chose
ne tournait pas rond et qu'il fallait
qu'on essaie de de sauver réellement nos
proches, nos équipes. Et ce qui était
vraiment intéressant, c'est que tout ça
se passait en même temps, en même temps
qu'on continuait notre notre métier. Et
ce qui était fou tout d'un coup, c'est
que on voit que parce qu'évidemment nos
collègues aux États-Unis, on leur parle
comme une journée normale et puis tout
d'un coup dans la nuit du mardi au
mercredi, on voit que les serveurs sont
ralentis et et donc on arrive c'est pas
qu'on arrive plus à accéder, c'est que
c'est extrêmement lent.
Et en fait, on a compris après que
Barklez qui était en train de de
racheter hein la partie américaine de de
l'emman, en fait, que tout ça se savait
déjà en fait aux États-Unis et qu'il y
avait une partie des drives qui étaient
en train d'être copié. Et donc en fait,
il s'est passé un truc complètement fou
qui était que alors qu'on se parlait et
qu'on avait quasiment tous des
opérations qui étaient transatlantique
parce qu'enfin où la plupart d'entre
nous, tout d'un coup, il y a une partie
de la firme qui pour se sauver ou enfin
on sait pas pourquoi enf en tout cas qui
était prête à copier des choses pour le
passer àel alors que c'était quelque
part notre bien commun puisqu'une une
une opération transatlantique c'était le
enfin ça appartenait aux deux côtés.
Enfin, il y avait pas un côté.
Évidemment, personne n'avait pensé à se
protéger de sa propre firme. Enfin, je
veux dire, c'était ça, ça n'avait pas de
enfin c'est pas quelque chose qui nous
était venu à l'esprit. Donc ça, c'est
des souvenir évidemment très marquant,
tout comme celui évidemment du rachat de
de Barkles. C'est des symboles mais
c'est c'est vraiment anecdotique mais
c'est absolument du vécu. Moi, je me
souviens à ce moment-là d'avoir reçu des
coups de fil de collègues américains qui
me disaient "Mais tu te rends compte ?
Tu te rends compte ce qu'ils ont fait ?"
Bon, je sais pas ce qui pouvait nous
arriver de pire, mais ils ont changé la
moquette, hein. Je me disais euh, jeis
pas compris au début le la chose, mais
il était vrai que la moquette de l'man
était verte, le vert les man, que l'man
avait une culture extrêmement forte euh
quasiment même, enfin certains parlaient
de sectes, c'est évidemment trop fort.
Couleur du dollar,
c'était Ouais. Enfin, on il y a il y a
peut-être un lien, je crois je crois
vraiment pas honnêtement et d'ailleurs,
c'était pas c'est tout simplement très
emblématique. Euh et Barkle a eu la
couleur bleue euh et donc ils avaient
compris, c'est ça qui était assez
intéressant, ils avaient compris que
l'intégration serait très difficile. Je
parle de Barkle et il s'était dit très
très rapidement dans le building
emblématique de de New York, il faut
arracher les moquettes, il faut
remplacer la moquette verte par la
moquette bleue parce que ils sont
attachés à leurs moquettes, enfin ils
sont attachés à ce qu'ils sont. Et ils
avaient évidemment changé le nom puisque
enfin défilé puisque c'est on est à Tam
Square hein donc défilait
les man et donc il s défiler Barkles en
bleu et cetera voilà et donc ça les gens
étaient enfin ça devenait des
conversations surréalistes de tu te
rends compte ils ont rechargé la
moquette alors que franchement encore
une fois il y avait il y avait peut-être
d'autres choses qui étaient plus
importantes mais c'est des jours de choc
de sidération et puis à ce moment-là bah
nous on se dit ben eux ont été rachetés
mais nous qu'est-ce qui se passe enfin
c'est juste des choses extrêmement et il
s'est passé des choses assez folles qui
était qu'on a continué à travailler.
Quand je dis sans poser de questions,
c'est pas forcément vrai aussi
précisément, mais sans trop interroger
pourquoi on faisait ça en travaillant
sur nos dossiers jusqu'à ce qu'après
derrière Nomur puisque Nomur après
racheté une enf l'autre partie qui
n'avait pas été rachetée par par
Barkles.
Je raconte ça parce que évidemment que
la grande histoire et pourquoi on en est
arrivé là est très intéressante, mais la
petite histoire du comportement humain
de ce qui se passe vraiment quand ça
arrive et je trouve intéressante,
sidérante, on dit aussi beaucoup sur les
comportements humains et moi je sais que
c'est ça que je retiens enfin en tout
cas je retiens profondément sur ce que
j'ai pu voir de des comportements à ce
moment-là. Alors, on va on va rentrer un
peu dans le vif du sujet, puis on va
parler Conseil aux États, on va parler
euh encore de petites histoires
crostillantes. Si on parlait un peu de
la grande histoire, comment on arrive à
avoir des banques systémiques, des
acteurs qui mentent au régulateur ?
Comment on en arrive à faire du window
dressing ? C'est quoi le window dressing
? C'est un peu masquer ou mettre ses
lunettes roses ou se présenter sur la la
meilleure la meilleure facette. Comment
on en arrive ? avoir dans les salles de
marché, dans les grandes banques, des
gens hors sol qui font de la
spéculation, qui se gavent, qui mettent
des gens au chômage, qui font fermer des
boîtes. Comment on en arrive à avoir
cette déconnexion ? Ça vient du système
éducatif, ça vient de la culture. On a
on a souvent sur internet la
comment on dit ça ? On dit cette légende
que le trader est coqué, le trader va
voir des péripathéticiennes,
le trader fait un peu n'importe quoi, le
lo Wall Street
et et ça c'est c'est le premier échelon,
c'est-à-dire la première échelon de
perception. On s'est amusé un peu à
infiltrer les milieux bancaires et à
voir les et à comprendre les grands
requins, ceux qui vont plonger à
Saint-Bart, ceux qui vont un petit peu
dans les Caraïbes et les voir dans leur
biotope. Et comment on en arrive à ça ?
Et pourquoi les États sont
démissionnaires face à cette conduite
mégalomane et prédatrice ?
Alors, je je vais répondre à la
question. Je veux pas répondre juste aux
quêtes d'espèces de l'man répondre
spécifiquement les manes et puis après
plus généralement
encore lié avec contrat avec eux ou pas
? les man il ils sont en faillite les
pauvres depuis longtemps. Euh non très
sérieusement sur les man je j'insiste
beaucoup là-dessus parce que c'est
quelque chose qu'on n'a pas assez
raconté et qui explique beaucoup de
choses. Déjà un, l'EMAN était devenu une
boîte en fait immobilière de spéculation
immobilière puisque quand on regarde
l'évolution du bilan de l'Éman
d'actifs qu'il y avait sur le bilan de
la banque immobiliers n'avait rien à
voir avec la mission de la banque ou
avec ce que la banque était censée
faire. pyramide de Pond, c'est ça ?
C'est pas forcément une pyramide de
Pondit. C'est tout simplement qu'une
banque comme l'man, si elle avait fait
le choix de tout d'un coup investir de
manière connue aussi de ses employés qui
étaient actionnaires puisque les
employés étaient à 48 % actionnaires de
l'Emman. Si ça avait été un choix assumé
de devenir un fond d'investissement
plus ou moins spéculatif, plutôt
spéculatif que moi dans l'immobilier,
bon il aurait fallu le dire comme ça. Et
c'est là où c'est aussi intéressant
parce que en tant qu'actionnaire de la
banque, c'est des choses qui finalement
n'ont pas autant que ça préoccupé les
banquiers. Et c'est là où quelque part
ce qui est intéressant, c'était plus
parce qu'on était dans nos dossiers que
parce qu'on surveillait ce qui se
passait. Non
non non non. C'est c'est là c'est très
spécifique à l'man et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut que je vous raconte en fait
ce qui s'est passé en 98 parce qu'en 98
Lesman quasiment disparaît
et tu as vraiment deux doigts de
disparaître. Et si on a pas ça en tête,
on comprend on comprend pas le reste. En
98, ce qui se passe crise russe, enfin
on sait. Et à ce moment-là déjà, il y a
au niveau des salles des marchés une
très grande défiance par rapport à les
manes. Et ce qui c'est souvent, on voit
ça dans les dans les volumes de salle de
marché. le marché du court terme, c'est
là où on voit le plus euh le la défiance
qui peut s'installer. Et donc ce qui se
passe, c'est qu'il y a plusieurs
journées dans lesquelles les volumes de
la salle des marchés sont très très très
bas et euh les traders qui sont sur
cette activité-là sont désespérés par
leur famille, par leurs copains, disent
"Oh, ça va très mal."
Et Dickfold donc qui est le patron de
Lman déjà à l'époque et qui le sera au
moment de la de la faillite
utilise une astuce ce que je dis est
évidemment véridique mais qui fait après
qu'il a eu et je vais la je vais la
raconter un statut de gourou et ce qui
amène aussi après à la fin de l'histoire
puisque ce qu'il fait en fait c'est
qu'il dit il passe derrière parce que
lui-même a commencé comme trader sur le
court terme donc c'est des métiers qu'il
connaît très très bien donc il passe
derrière C'était essentiellement des
hommes en leur disant "Mais arrête de de
de dire à ta femme que ceci mais arrête
de dire à ton collègue de GP Morgan que
ça ne fonctionne pas." Tu raccroches et
tu leur dis "Désolé, je suis en train de
faire un trade".
Et là les gens le regardent quand même,
enfin ils savent que il connait les
marchés mais ils se disent "Oui" et
alors ? Il dit "Mais si, mais si mais
si, tu vas voir, ça va remonter." Bon et
donc il fait appliquer ça à la chaîne
donc un trading floor enfin on imagine
un long voilà donc à la chaîne à la
chaîne à la chaîne. Et donc ils font
tous cette astuce qui est quand même une
astuce un peu carçon de bain. Bon et
véridique les volumes c'est alors c'est
lent hein mais en allez 48 72 he on est
revenu au même niveau que enfin un bas
mais en tous les cas un niveau normal
pour une salle de marché. Donc c'est
cette astuce là mise en œuvre par le
patron lui-même parce qu'il faut voir
qu'il est c'est le patron donc il
descend dans la salle. Enfin il y a
quand même des sujets de hiérarchie qui
existent dans dans dans ce métier. Donc
il descend dans la salle, il donne la
recette, la recette marche
et donc il est vu comme le sauveur,
comme le type qui ne se trompe jamais,
comme celui qui sait. Et même quand
c'est désespéré, il sait. Et ça ça
explique beaucoup de choses parce que ça
explique alors après les manex beaucoup
de choses pour vous.
Non non, ça explique beaucoup de choses
dans aussi l'aveuglement
qu'on pu avoir ceux qui auraient aussi
dû être des vigiles de tout ça,
c'est-à-dire les actionnaires, les
employés. Enfin, c'est c'est ça que je
sais en effet pour moi et pour nous en
tant qu'employé l'emprise psychologique
de son patron, c'est ça ? Non, c'est pas
que l'emprise psychologique, c'est le
fait de il a déjà sauvé la banque et là
il y a eu un problème de gouvernance
parce que il a déjà sauvé la banque et
les gens étaient beaucoup moins
attentifs. Quand je dis les gens, c'est
les employés, c'est évidemment les gens
qui l'avaient nommé qui étaient plutôt
des gens complaisants et ceux qui ne
l'étaient pas sont de toute manière soit
parti soit voilà donc qui étaient
complaisant autour de lui. Et après il
s'était construit une aa dans le marché
où il a poussé aussi les choses un peu
loin puisqueaprès il y a eu des
règlements de compte à Wall Street qui
ont fait que certaines décisions ont été
prise et ça c'était aussi très lié à ça,
on va dire ça son caractère qui faisait
qu' qu'il avait beaucoup eu beaucoup
d'ennemis. Mais c'est la combinaison de
tout ça qui fait que quelque part on en
arrive à une situation où franchement
enfin les 3 mois avant la chute de
l'emman,
n'importe qui connaît quand même un peu
le métier de ce que c'est qu'être
banquier voit qu'il y a quelque chose
qui ne tourne pas. On a de on a des cols
internes où on nous explique mais des
choses que nous-même en tant que
banquier on n'urait jamais osé dire à
qui que ce soit en terme de enfin de
mais si ça va remonter. Enfin,
évidemment, c'était beaucoup beaucoup
plus complexe que ça, mais c'était des
choses dont on savait que ça ne
fonctionnait pas. Donc, c'est le sujet,
c'est pas c'est pas l'emprise. C'est le
sujet d'une gouvernance qui déraille
complètement. C'est le sujet d'une
banque qui devient en effet beaucoup
plus spéculative qu'elle qu'elle ne
devrait être. C'est le sujet de un Wall
Street tout à fait roi qui après décide
qui on sauve et qui on sauve pas.
puisque certaines banques, enfin per
Sterns, d'autres ont d'autres ont vu ce
que pouvait donner tener les choses et
certaines ont été sauvées parce que la
réalité c'est que les manons mais on
sait très bien que derrière euh il y
avait MIL, il y avait d'autres enfin je
veux dire clairement il y a eu un choix
à ce moment-là qui est un choix
politique de dire que on va punir ces
excès et comme par hasard on punit aussi
celui qui était finalement c'est pas à
la marge mais qui était celui qui par un
caractère insupportable arrogant et
cetera s'était mis le plus à la marge et
avait défié certains autres qui étaient
considérés dans ce mil-là se considér
eux-mêmes comme les comme les rois. Et
c'est pour ça qu'il y a pas les
garanties de passif qui sont données
quand euh alors qu'on aurait pu faire
ça. Enfin, la faillite était quelque
chose qui était évitable. Mais au
moment, alors j'étais pas évidemment pas
dans la pièce quand la décision s'est
prise, mais au moment en tout cas je ce
que j'ai vécu moi, c'est les différents
calls d'update qui étaient passés à des
gens qui avaient un certain niveau de
sécorité quand on dans dans dans cette
banque. Je pense quand même en avoir vu
suffisamment pour être capable de dire
qu'à ce moment-là, quand la décision de
la faillite est prise par les autorités
américaines, ils veulent punir et aussi
quelque part que
des gens en prison.
Alors, j'y reviendrai ça parce que c'est
c'est important justement parce que
Dickfold a remonté un une affaire. Donc
donc justement je reviendrai mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'à ce moment-là
ils veulent punir et en même temps qu'on
regarde pas trop ce qu'ils ont fait à
côté. Enfin tout ça est très clair. Mais
ce qui est vraiment intéressant c'est
qu'à ce moment-là personne ne comprend
les ramifications de ce que ça va
entraîner parce que personne n'a en tête
et ça c'est un aspect de temps en temps
quand il y a des décisions qui sont
prises où on pense que tout est
réfléchi, calculé et cetera. Ça peut
être le cas dans certaines décisions où
il y a des choses extrêmement cyniques
et peut-être qu'on parlera de la Grèce
où là il y a c'était un plan extrêmement
construit. Donc ça c'est différent. Là
au moment où ils prennent cette
décisionlà personne ne se dit "Ah alors
que c'est du bon sens mais il y a
peut-être une ligne de swap où il y a
peut-être quelque chose avec une
entreprise française
ou avec une PME allemande. Vous parlez
de la Grèce ? Non non, je disais pour
pour les je disais pour les Manes
personne au moment où ils prennent la
décision de mettre les Mannes en
faillite,
je suis intimement persuadé que personne
au trésor américain n'imagine toutes les
ramifications
de du séisme que ça va de l'époque. Ben
Bernon de l'époque parce que c'était
l'époque de Ben, c'est ça ? Oui. Il
vous pensez pas qu'il a compris les
effets dominaux que ça pouvait avoir
les l'impact
aussi fort des effets dominaux. Je ne
crois pas parce que je crois sincèrement
qu'ils ont pensé qu'en faisant un
exemple mais en sauvant derrière ça
montrerait qu'il y a des choses qu'on ne
peut pas faire. Mais
ça c'est votre interprétation. Oui, je
je enfin on a jamais de certitude mais
enfin je suis j'ai quand même une
conviction forte que c'est que c'est ça
et qu'il y avait et qu'on a choisi cette
banque là pour des raisons encore une
fois qui étaient lié aussi à son à son
patron parce qu' aussi on pensait
qu'elle était peut-être moins connectée
que d'autres et qu'il y aurait peut-être
moins d'impact mais aussi on a
sous-estimé l'impact tout ça parce que
les sauvetages vous savez j'en veux pour
preuve mais c'est c'est peut-être une
une lecture qui qui est personnelle les
sauvetages après derrière se sont
enchaînés quand même IG et cetera. Donc
donc voilà. Donc donc si vraiment le
plan avait été aussi bien huilé, on va
dire qu'il y a on agit un peu dans la
panique après derrière quand même. Donc
alors si je résume bien, si j'ai bien
compris,
je vais résumer les choses trivialement.
On se retrouve avec des banques
systémiques. Systémiqu c'est ça veut
dire qui peuvent faire effondrer tout le
système
avec des permettez-moi l'expression des
bénis. Ouioui mal fini incapable de se
projeter et de projeter leur décision
avec un cursus long comme le bras mais
ça reste quand même des binioui de temps
en temps un peu toxicoman avec un
syndrome mégalomane on est d'accord hein
c'est pas du tout exagéré
c'est pas non mais j'exagère pas vous
avez jamais été à vous retrouvez Non moi
je je je vais pas forc
donc laissez-moi terminer si je peux me
permettre et on se retrouve avec une
myiade
de de clones de de qui reproduisent
d'une façon moutonnière cette
transhumance
et on se retrouve nous à les refinancer
derrière parce que ils ont été un peu
punis. Qui a été en prison dans cette
histoire là ? Attendez, il il faut
distinguer le cas de plusieurs banques
parce qu'en fait toutes les banques
n'ont pas fait la même chose. Donc c'est
quand même important d'avoir mais mais
je veux me permettre de résumer votre
résumé qui est de dire il y avait en
effet à la tête de l'man un trader qui
faisait du trading sur sa banque. Sauf
que un trader peut avoir un bou lui
c'était du trading sur la banque. Et je
personnalise beaucoup parce que les
organes de gouvernance autour de lui qui
auraient dû jouer leur rôle n'ont pas
joué leur rôle pour des raisons qui leur
appartiennent et où il y avait
certainement
des choses qui étaient pas forcément
extrêmement positives. Juste pour
déposséder la responsabilité du pouce
bouton. Non. Ah non non mais absolument
pas. Au contraire, Jacob. Jacable en
disant que à la tête d'une banque qui en
effet avait l'importance, même si
l'importance de l'EMAN a été
sous-estimée, mais quand bien même
l'emman était quand même une banque
importante. Il y avait à la tête de
l'EMAN quelqu'un qui se livrait à des
activités de trading hautement enfin
l'équivalent hein, je résume là
beaucoup, hautement spéculative, entouré
de gens qui le laissaient faire qui lui
laissaient faire les choses sans les
dénoncer. et quelques-uns qui se sont
interrogés ont après, comme je l'ai dit,
enfin euh ont soit tiré les
conséquences, soit après euh on on leur
a on les a remercié. Donc c'est ça la
réalité. Donc elle est pas
qui est en prison.
Donc alors sur le sur le en prison, en
effet, les gens qui l'ont été l'ont pas
forcément été pour ces pour ces raisons
l'ont pas forcément été pour ces pour
ces raisons-là et plutôt pour des sujets
de droit commun. Euh et en effet, il n'y
a pas eu de procès, il y a eu des
hearings évidemment comme ça c'est
souvent le cas aux États-Unis, mais il
n'y a pas eu de procès. Euh
non, il y a pas
hearings, c'est c'est un peu euh
Oui. Non, parce que dès qu'il y a une
affaire comme ça, enfin, il y a beaucoup
de enfin c'est juste que je très
traditionnel, enfin je veux dire, il y a
rien d'exceptionnel. C'est pour apaiser
la plebe, c'est pour montrer qu'on
justifie son salaire, qu'on non,
c'était vu là comme une mission
d'information plus qu'autre chose.
Très jolimenté. Non non mais mais très
franchement ça été quasiment à ça que ça
a servi puisque en effet quelles ont
réellement été les conséquences ? Pas
vraiment et comme je l'ai dit Dickf a
remonté après une affaire. Alors après
est-ce que c'est Dickfou qui est le plus
condamnable je je dis pas sur les ces
actes passés de remonter une affaire où
est-ce que les gens qui c'est les gens
qui lui confient quelque chose ? J'ai
plutôt tendance à penser que les gens
qui confient quelque chose, c'est aussi
poser aussi question mais bien sûr que
alors que il y a eu des conséquences en
effet de domino évidemment sur des un
nombre incroyable de gens dans le monde
de cette prise de décision qui est quand
même attribuable aussi au trésor
américain. Enfin, il faut il faut aussi
remettre remettre les choses. La
deuxième des choses, il y a évidemment
aussi beaucoup d'employés de de l'emmè
perdu leur perdu leur job. Donc c'est
enfin, il était responsable quand même à
priori aussi de de ses employés. Euh et
après évidemment euh toutes les
ramifications qui allaient euh qui
allaient derrière. Donc là-dessus, il y
a pas eu de conséquences euh fortes qui
ont été euh qui ont été tirées de tout
ça.
Il y a pas eu de conséquence, donc il y
a pas eu trop de prison, ça a été tout
tout va bien. Revenons revenons au au
cœur de de la centrale nucléaire. Euh
euh
pas de lanceur d'alerte pour prévenir
qu'on faisait n'importe quoi. Les
lanceurs d'alerte dans la banque, ils
sont traité comment ? Ils sont traités
du genre où ils sont genre on graisse un
peu des pattes. Le comment ça se passe ?
C'est c'est vous avez eu affaire à des
gens qui sont venus voir en disant voilà
bon j'ai un problème là on me demande de
faire ça quand même. C'est bordeur.
Non moi je je me suis jamais trouvé dans
cette situation là. J'ai
c'est des gens qui ont qui ont été
amenés à gérer ce type de situation.
Je je connais des gens qui ont posé des
questions sur des sur des choses en
s'interrogeant sur ce qu'on faisait.
Moi, j'ai moi-même aussi pu dans
certains cas poser des questions et et
après non mais en disant tout simplement
je ne comprends pas pourquoi pourquoi on
fait ça. Enfin, oui, il y avait il y
avait quelque chose enfin je je peux pas
dire pour quel pour quel client c'était,
mais je me souviens d'un appel de
quelqu'un qui n'était pas de Lesman et
qui me dit "Il y a ce truc absolument
miraculeux qu'il faut que tu vendes à
cette cette entreprise française qui a
beaucoup de cash euh et qui
l'entreprise
bien tenté l'entreprise qui a beaucoup
de en fait les pauvres en plus ils ont
vraiment rien à voir dans cette affaire
c'était tout simplement ils avaient
beaucoup de cash et donc la la personne
qui était un des clients de les man
Il faut que tu fasses ça. Il y aura
beaucoup de fils à la clé pour toi. F le
fils,
il y aura beaucoup de commission. Tu
pourra charger beaucoup de commission.
Oui. Voilà. Alors ce qui veut ce qui
veut tout et rien dire, ce que je veux
dire par là, c'est que ça veut dire ça
veut dire non justement laissez-moi
raconter jusqu'au bout parce que c'est
le bout qui est intéressant et c'est
chacun est responsable et doit ramener
des résultats à la banque. Donc c'était
dans ce contexte là qui c'était genre tu
augmenteras ton chiffre si on peut
appeler ça comme ça, même si ce que je
faisais n'était pas du chiffre, j'étais
pas dans la salle des marchés. Moi, je
fais je faisais quelque chose côté côté
banque d'investissement, donc de l'autre
côté du mur. Mais peu importe, comme je
m'occupais de client français, j'ai reçu
cet appel là de tu devrais, tu vois ça.
Et alors donc moi, bonne ou mauvaise
habitude, j'en sais rien mais je
considère que normalement quelque chose
doit le comprendre. Bon et là je ne
comprenais rien mais quand je dis rien
vraiment rien. Et on avait beau me dire
il y a un rendement formidable mais non
tu comprends pas il y a des produits
structurés et cetera je dis mais j'ai
quand même fait des maths donc mais ce
qui n'est pas non plus un signe
d'intelligence mais je disais quand même
je devrais comprendre s'il y a quelque
chose. Et l'ironie et ça j'ai j'ai gardé
hein le le le le mail alors que je garde
je garde peu de choses. C'était un
produit Madof. Bon voilà, donc tout ça
pour dire "Oui mais oui oui mais c'est
marrant
pyramide.
Oui mais c'est mais c'est marrant. Ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que on
peut juste dire bah oui évidemment je
vais le faire par c'est ça on n'est pas
forcément il y a des peut-être des gens
qui sont pas forcément mal intentionnés
à dire je vais vendre ce produit qui
vont pas chercher à comprendre. Bon
évidemment que c'est irresponsable. Vous
devez chercher à comprendre ce que vous
ce que vous ce que vous vendez. Et oui,
il peut y avoir la pas du gain et
cetera. Et donc oui, mais c'est là où il
faut être un homme, une femme libre et
savoir et d'ailleurs, c'est aussi ce que
ces écoles peuvent vous peuvent vous
apprendre quelque part. Gardez la tête
froide, liberté de jugement. Quelque
chose vous semble pas être clair ou vous
avez pas travaillé votre dossier, bah
vous engagez pas. Enfin, je dire après,
c'est un minimum de responsabilité.
Comment on fait pour savoir si on est
libre ?
Ben, je pense qu'en tant qu'individu, si
on est suffisamment vertébré, on est
libre. En tout cas, moi je me suis
toujours considéré comme libre. Moi,
j'ai j'ai commencé,
il faut déjà commencer par faire bouger
ces chaînes.
Attendez, moi j'ai commencé chez les
manes et j'ai pu rencontrer des gens
là-bas qui étaient des gens que j'ai
admiré en tant que personne humaine,
mentor et avec qui j'ai gardé des liens.
J'ai toujours considéré que un du jour
au lendemain parce que je je disais non
à quelque chose ou je voulais pas faire
quelque chose, je pouvais être mis
dehors. Je travaillais aux États-Unis et
à Londres. Donc les les les choses se
faisaient assez rapidement. Vous
appelez, vous prenez votre carton.
Enfin, c'est pas des légendes, hein.
C'est comme ça que ça se passait. Et que
je pouvais aussi dire à tout moment et
que je devais me trouver en position à
tout moment de dire "Bah, en fait, je
pars, j'ai géré, enfin j'ai vécu, je vis
toute ma vie comme ça." Donc enfin après
ça veut pas dire que on peut pas se
laisser influencer. Enfin, il faut pas
être idiot non plus. Bon, mais justement
quand on voit que quelqu'un vous dit
tiens, tu devrais faire si ou tu devrais
enfin moi la première chose que je fais
c'est de me dire déjà un quel est
l'intérêt de cette personne de me dire
ça pour quelle est cette chose là ? et
on l'analyse, on la regarde est-ce que
et ensuite après est-ce qu'elle est
vraiment bonne pour au cas d'espèce là,
est-ce que c'était vraiment bien pour
cette compagnie française ? Donc il y a
quand même enfin ça demande un peu de
travail et justement ne pas juste dire
"Ah oui tiens pouvoir gagner beaucoup
d'argent enfin c'est c'est enfin certain
c'est quoi ? Pardon ?
C'est quoi beaucoup d'argent ?
Ça ça dépend de quoi on parle. Soit on
peut parler de combien la banque aurait
gagné et là enfin très franchement je je
ne me je je me souviens plus mais
certainement des dizaines de millions
sur une transaction de ce de ce de ce
type là et après les banquiers avaient
des bonus qui étaient qui étaient
d'ailleurs et en action enfin quand la
quand les compagnies étaient côté ce qui
n'est pas le cas de toutes les banques
et enfin donc un mélange de salaires
fixes et de bonus avec une part en une
part en cash et une part en en action et
qui était en effet des des sommes qui
sont extrêmement importants. Mais c'est
aussi ça qui vous oblige, c'est parce
que justement vous savez que ce sont ces
sommes-là qui sont en jeu, que vous
devez avoir une colonne vertébrale et
que vous devez savoir où vous habitez et
avoir les pieds sur terre.
Votre plus gros bonus chez eux, c'était
combien ?
Ça intéresse personne.
C'est intéressant.
Non mais non, ça pas. Voilà. Et
d'ailleurs, vous voulez que je vous dise
en fait comme moi j'étais quelque part
d'une aussi d'une certaine peut-être
stupidité, je sais pas, mais en tout
cas, j'ai vendu aucune des actions.
Donc la faillite répond à la question
mais ça n'a aucune importance.
C'est intéressant pour vous comprendre.
Oui, mais ce que je dire pour moi, ça
n'a aucune importance. C'est-à-dire j'ai
enfin je je je me je m'explique
peut-être autrement. Euh je sais qu'il y
a d'ailleurs toujours des procès euh qui
sont en cours parce que il y a des gens
qui essayent de récupérer les actifs.
Enfin, quand je dis ils essayent de
récupérer, c'est juste une procédure de
faillite en fait hein. Donc les les
actifs sont récupérés progressivement.
Je sais qu'il y a des enfin pour il y
avait une procédure évidemment pour les
employés actionnaires pour pouvoir voir
si on récupérait quelque chose à la fin
d'un très très long processus puisque
c'est on était les derniers de la chaîne
et très très clairement je moi j'ai pas
rempli cette j'ai pas rempli ça je
quelque part je voilà ça me
on on va rester encore sur l'écume des
choses juste juste un détail comment
vous expliquez les manipulations du
ribor et de le ribord
est-ce qu'il faut les expliquer C'est
autrement que que les autres
spéculations, je crois pas. Enfin, c'est
tout simplement des gens qui dans un
marché essayent de voir s'il y a une
inefficience et qui essaie d'en
profiter. Donc si ce n'est quelque part
la volonté de générer de l'argent et de
générer du profit, je sais pas
l'expliquer autrement, mais je traiterai
pas ces manipulations là différemment de
d'autres. Il est évident que comme c'est
sur des instruments qui sont entre
guillemets importants, le sous-jacent
est évidemment très important. Donc nous
l'intérêt de pouvoir éventuellement
penser que c'est intéressant de spéculer
là-dessus, mais c'est tout simplement
c'est c'est quelque chose.
Je vous coupe, on on va la la haute
finance, ça peut être compliqué pour
certaines personnes qui qui essayent de
nous écouter. Je vais vous demander de
m'expliquer le Ribor et le Ribor comme
un hongrois qui a souscrit un un emprunt
à taux variable.
C'est qui est qui est un très bon
exemple. Donc il faudrait que j'explique
aussi le franc suisse et d'autres et
d'autres mon
s'était adossé au fran suisse
d'ailleurs.
Exactement. Il il y avait il y avait
quelques quelques fantaisies en yenne en
plus. Non. Alors ce que ce que ce que ce
que c'est alors pour essayer de
d'expliquer ça de manière de manière
claire, dans un emprunt, vous avez ce
qu'on appelle un taux sans risque. Et
alors après en fonction des monnaies, si
c'est de l'euro c'est de l'oribor. Si
c'est du la livre sterlin, c'est aussi
un Libor ou ça peut être un Libor
américain. Voilà.
Et donc, mais ça c'est du court terme.
Donc mettons-nous d'abord sur les taux
sans sans risque. Ça c'est les taux
gouvernementaux. Et à ça, vous ajoutez
une marge qui est le risque de ce que de
l'emprunt que vous que vous contractez.
Donc si un état empreinte, c'est le taux
sans risque de l'État mais qui a déjà
le risque son risque de crédit à
l'intérieur. Typiquement, ça serait par
exemple un État africain qui peut
s'endetter en dollars, ce qui pas
toujours la chose la plus intelligente,
mais ça serait un taux US trasories,
hein, et qu'on pourrait convertir parce
que c'est un taux long, ça c'est
généralement un taux 10 ans, un taux 30
ans, qu'on pourrait convertir en Libor
si on voulait parce que ça c'est des
très court termes, c'est du Libor 1
mois, 2 mois, 3 mois et cetera plus une
marge de crédit qui généralement se
calcule en point de base et les points
de base généralement c'est l'équivalent
de de pourcent sans points de C'est 1 %.
Et donc je enfin je prends juste un
exemple. Si c'est 5 % on a le taux de
base. Disons que c'est 1 ce que je dis
n'est pas exact mais c'est juste pour
donner un exemple. C'est 1 + 4 qui
serait la marge de de crédit. Donc ça
c'est comme ça que fonctionne un
emprunt. Alors là euh on on se dit déjà
un pays africain qui s'endettete en
dollars. Alors il faudra quand même
regarder un jour le lien entre la parité
donc de sa propre monnaie quelque part
et de celle du et de celle du dollar.
Mais si on fait le parallèle euh
hongrois, quand vous faites un a priori
hein euh quand vous êtes en Hongrie, si
vous faites un emprunt immobilier,
puisque la plupart du temps c'était
plutôt immobilier et même de temps en
temps euh des crédits à la consommation,
mais restons sur du domestique, euh a
priori c'est plutôt en forte, enfin
c'est plutôt dans votre monnaie locale.
Et donc
les banques en effet et ont proposé des
produits dans lequels le hongrois, la
hongroise conttait une dette en yenne
ou en France suisse
ou en France suisse exactement alors que
bah leur enfin leur revenus leurs
ressources étaient en forête. Bon donc
si on imagine une parité absolument
stable dans tout ça, bon on voit à peu
près ce qu'on doit rembourser. Sauf que
ça évidemment ça n'existe pas dans la
vraie vie et que s'il y a des mouvements
de monnaie, on peut tout d'un coup se
retrouver à devoir rembourser deux fois
plus, trois fois plus, 10 fois plus que
ce qu'on a initialement emprunté.
Utiliser ce type de mécanisme en terme
de guerre économique ?
Je sais pas si en terme de guerre
économique, mais je vais y revenir. Je
veux juste terminer sur le sur ce sujet
Hongour parce que ce qui est fou, c'est
que pourquoi ? Parce qu'on peut se dire
finalement, ils sont vraiment bêtes ces
hongis. Bah non, pas du tout.
Ils sont vraiment corrompus. Euh alors
on pourrait le dire mais sauf que au cas
d'espèces là c'est tout simplement parce
que le yen ou le franc- suisse au moment
où ça se passe les taux en yenne et en
franc- suisse sont bas et donc personne
n'est censé avoir un doctorat ou un PhD
en finance. Et en effet, si votre
banque, enfin peu importe votre
conseiller financier, enfin je sais pas
qui vous dit "Alors, tu pensais que tu
allais payer 7 %, 8 % enfin peu importe,
mais moi j'ai le truc formidable pour
toi, tu vas payer 2 %." Bon, a priori on
peut se dire "Bah moi, je vais quand
même plutôt aller chercher le 2 % que
d'aller chercher le 7 %." Je je le fais
évidemment de manière très grossière,
mais c'est ça ce qui s'est passé, c'est
il n'a évidemment été expliqué à
personne. Bien sûr qu'on leur a dit
c'est en il y a un truc en France
suisse, il y a un truc en Yen mais dire
ça et expliquer le risque qui consiste à
dire mais si jamais les monnaies bougent
dans tel sens, voilà ce que ça va
donner. Évidemment ça n'a jamais été
fait.
Je peux vous couper ?
Oui bien sûr. Et j'ai pas répondu à la
question, je suis désolé. Non, mais
c'est c'est la réponse peut-être pas
intéressante, mais c'est la manière dont
vous expliquez et votre arborescence de
et votre construction de pensée qui nous
intéresse.
Je je vous pose un peu la question, mais
si derrière il y a des gens dans des
banques qui manipulent les taux pour
s'en mettre plein les fouilles, le petit
hongrois, OK, j'accepte l'explication,
c'est pas de bol madame Michu, on vous a
pas prévenu sur les risques. Bon bah
vous avez pas lu les petites lignes,
vous avez pas de piège à votre haute
finance, maintenant vous payez. OK, ça
on s'en mort les doigts. Mais si
derrière il y a des gens au sein des
salles de marché qui font une petite
entente pour s'en mettre plein les
fouilles. Mais j'irai même pas jusque-
là parce que le vrai sujet, il est la
différence d'information entre les deux
parce que le particulier hongrois et et
et quel que soit son niveau d'éducation
n'a pas à savoir comprendre ce qui va
lui arriver en fonction de la
fluctuation du franc suisse par rapport
au forint ou au yen par rapport au
forint. Par contre, la personne dans la
banque ou en tous les cas des gens dans
cette banque parce que voilà, eux savent
que si jamais il y a telle ou telle
fluctuation en ou là c'est encore plus
grave que ce qu'on pense non mais donc
c'est pas possible. Donc ils le savent.
Ils savent que euh cette fluctuation bah
peut se tourner dans un sens ou dans un
autre et eux se sont déjà
d'une manière ou d'une autre ou ou s'ils
l'ont pas fait là sur le coup c'est à
leur banque qui font prendre beaucoup de
risques. Donc là aussi je pense qu'ils
se sont gés et donc quelque part d'un
ils se sont protégés contre des
mouvements de monnaie. Donc vous avez
d'un côté quelqu'un qui est informé qui
en plus en temps réel plus n c'est pas
juste en temps réel accès à toute
l'information parce que vous pouvez
avoir des recherches qui vous disent je
pense que la parité entre les deux
monnaies va dire ça ça ça de toutes les
tous les gens qui étudient ça dans le
monde. Donc un accès qu'on va appeler
parfait à l'information. Ensuite,
l'accès aux techniques financières qui
permettent de se protéger, de se couvrir
contre ces fluctuations de monnaie de la
manière la plus optimale puisqueà priori
ça fait partie des compétences de la
banque. Donc on va on va se dire qu'ils
sont compétents sur ce sujetl. Donc ça
c'est d'un côté évidemment dans un but
de profit enfin pas pour autre chose. Et
de l'autre côté vous avez le particulier
hongrois qui lui enfin et encore une
fois même s'il pourrait se dire tiens il
y a deux monnaaies différentes mais
c'est pas à lui de se dire ça. C'est pas
à lui de le de comprendre. C'est pas à
lui de faire ses simulations. Et c'est
ça qui va pas. c'est la différence
d'information entre les deux et que ça
n'ait pas été expliqué, proposé et après
vous avez un hongroit qui dit je
absolument spéculer sur le forin et le
fran suisse. Bon enfin qui après c'est
son problème, c'est autre chose mais
c'était pas du tout ce que les gens
demandaient et qui se sont après
retrouvés dans des situations évidemment
personnelles. Enfin, tout à fait tout à
fait abominable. Non mais tout à fait
tout à fait abominable. Et en plus on ne
compr c'est ça le pire c'est que c'est
enfin le pire tout est pire mais en ne
comprenant en plus pas ce qui leur été
arrivé. C'estàd c'est avec en plus une
non prédictibilité du risque. C'estd
vous avez pris un risque mais en fait
vous savez pas vraiment pourquoi. Alors
après il y a évidemment ceux qui vous
disent oui enfin à 2 % ils auraient dû
savoir. Bah non en fait non c'est c'est
la pire des phrases que j'ai jamais pu
entendre hein. Donc
on s'en fait une autre comme ça. Quand
vous voyez autour de 2006, 2007, 2008,
plein de banquiers qui viennent
démarcher, par exemple des communautés
d'agglomération,
d'autres choses comme ça avec des des
variables, qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
C'est parce que plus ils en fourguent,
plus ils s'en mettent dans les poches ou
parce qu'ils veulent aider, ils sont
philanthropes, ils veulent aider les
communautés d'agglomération en leur
proposant des taux bas. Et en face, on a
des directeurs des finances bon un peu
perchés. qui aime bien recevoir des
boîtes de CD, des caisses de vin, des
invitations à gauche et à droite ou où
c'est quoi ? C'est parce que il y a une
incompréhension, il y a un manque de
connaissance ou c'est de depuis plus
loin en fait les gens qui travaillent
dans la finance sont simplement des gens
qui sculptent de l'air chaud et qui
brassent de la fumée et qui font des
profits adossés à que dalle.
Non mais il y a des il y a des
Je me fais un peu volontairement.
Non, bien sûr, bien sûr. Mais il y a en
fait je je il y a le même phénomène que
dans le phénomène hongroise,
c'est-à-dire une divergence
d'information forte et vous voulez pas
non plus demander à au responsable d'une
région d'être le spécialiste des
produits structurés. Ce que vous pouvez
lui demander par contre, c'est d'éviter
d'en prendre s'il comprend pas ce qu'il
fait et et d'avoir une responsabilité
par rapport à ses administrés.
Une responsabilité
par rapport à ses administrés. Bah oui.
On vit pas dans une époque où personne
n'est responsable de n'importe quoi.
Mais on on y on y viendra. Mais c'est ça
ce que vous pouvez lui demander, pas
d'être spécialiste de pricing de
produits dérivés. Ça ça ça non.
Vous connaissez beaucoup de directeurs
financiers de ce genre de de d'usine à
gaz régional ? Je et il ne je pense
ils sont censés être formés ces gens-là.
Euh
quand vous avez une communauté
d'agglomération qui gère à peu près un
milliard,
ils sont quand même censés être formés
ces gens-là. Il y a une différence entre
être formé aux techniques financières et
ils le sont et après comprendre
l'intégralité de produits extrêmement
structuré qu'on vous propose où vous
n'avez d'ailleurs même pas vous-même les
outils. Je je parle pour les
décortiquer. Donc la prudence et la
responsabilité c'est de ne pas s'engager
dans quelque chose où quel manifestement
on ne maîtrise pas tout. Non, non pas
parce qu'on n' pas la compétence, on n
pas les outils, on n' pas
l'appréciation, mais je je veux revenir
là-dessus sur aussi sur le plein les
poches et cetera. Ce qui est demandé et
ce qui peut être demandé à certains
banquiers dans certaines circonstances
parce que là aussi le mot banquier est
un mot où il faut faire attention dans
ce qu'on dit. de détail et la banque
d'affaires.
Oui. Et et surtout en fait on est dans
le paradoxe le plus grand et c'est dire
combien les choses ont été dévoyé. Et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut dire ça et
qu'il faut expliquer ça parce que la
réalité c'est que votre banquier a
priori c'est celui que vous allez voir
quand vous voulez acheter un logement.
C'est celui que vous allez voir si vous
avez un projet professionnel. Donc a
priori, c'est quelqu'un qui est un
partenaire et qui vous permet de vous
aider à trouver les financements pour
réaliser votre projet. Non mais juste
parce qu'il faut revenir à la base qui
raconte ça c'est ce qui raconte dans la
pub. Non non, attendez, c'est faut juste
revenir à la base de ce qu'est
normalement la banque. Et il y a
beaucoup de banquiers qui font leur dans
des dans des agences euh je je citer le
nom par ça n'a pas de sens mais qui dans
des agences peuvent changer la vie de
certains projets, de certains
entrepreneurs, de certains enfin moi en
tant que
certaines sociétés carrément.
Oui. Non mais moi non mais et et moi en
tant que en tant qu'entrepreneur, je moi
je peux vous dire que j'ai les
discussions alors c'est intéressant
puisque comme j'ai j'ai pu avoir
l'expérience d'avant, les discussions
avec mes banquiers sont sont
intéressantes. Bon mais donc déjà ils
ont compris qu'il fallait pas me
proposer des choses qui qui n'avaient
pas de sens mais au-delà de ça ce qui
est intéressant c'est justement que je
je le vois comme quelque chose de comme
partenaire en fait. J'essaie de le faire
avec la banque idéale telle que moi
j'aimerais qu'elle fonctionne.
C'est-à-dire en les tenant au courant de
ce qu'on fait nous, de pourquoi on
progresse, de pourquoi est-ce qu'on est
une entreprise à mission, de pourquoi on
continue à embaucher alors que c'est la
crise. Non mais je pour leur expliquer
ça et je veux dire que c'est ce
partenariat là qui compte et que les
banques devraient avoir des ressources
qui sont utilisées à ça. Et je veux
vraiment qu'on distingue ça qui est
important du reste parce que le reste
devrait
Oui. parce que le reste
parce que c'est pas le cas
et parce que parce que les deux
activités et ça c'est un débat qui est
très intéressant parce que les deux
activités perdurent la plupart du temps
au sein des banques et que
des activités plus de marché ou de
spéculation he qui fait la banque en
fait.
Exactement. Et donc c'est ça aussi ce
qui pose la question des rentabilités et
des et parce que à la fin évidemment
c'est de ça dont on parle mais et j'ai
je reviens sur les sujets spéculatifs
mais je veux vraiment insister sur
quelque chose. Vous savez, moi j'ai
travaillé sur un des projets que je
considère vraiment comme un projet qui
me tient vraiment à cœur au Sénégal ou
avec un petit groupe et quelqu'un
d'exceptionnel qui est le patron de ce
qui cette agence maintenant Papsar pour
les pour les femmes et qui fait en fait
et qui à la tête d'une agence pour les
femmes l'entrepreneuriat rapide pour les
femmes et les jeunes et cet homme son
équipe parce que tu c'est jamais c'est
jamais individuel c'est le genre de chos
sont exceptionnels. du microcrédit. Ça
veut dire que vous avez une femme, donc
c'est c'est en fait une banque hein,
donc c'est vous avez une femme qui a
besoin d'aller acheter du poisson pour
le vendre au marché. Elle a pas les
ressources pour le faire. Et bien cette
agence là lui donne les ressources. La
seule condition, c'est qu'elle se
bancarise, donc qu'elle ait un compte et
qu'on puisse donc lui verser de l'argent
de manière indépendante de son mari
puisque c'est voilà donc pour c'est par
par protection. Mais et donc je je parle
de ça parce que il y a plein de projets.
Alors ça c'est le projet le plus petit
peut-être. Après ceux qui veulent ouvrir
des salons de coiffure, il y a ceux qui
veulent faire un peu des start-ups. Mais
on pourrait penser que il peut y avoir
beaucoup d'accidents de crédit et que il
faudrait une rentabilité incroyable et
qu'il faudrait se protéger du risque et
cetera. Et ce que ce projet a réussi à
faire, c'est à dire on vous prête de
l'argent, soyez responsable avec cet
argent parce qu'en fait c'est l'argent
du Sénégal puisque ça a commencé avec
une ligne budgétaire. Donc soyez
responsables avec cet argent.
Maintenant, votre projet, on le valide
avec vous. C'est-à-dire, on a eu des cas
dans lequels il y avait certains qui
voulaient faire de l'élevage dans des
régions où l'élevage qui souhaitait
faire n'avait pas de sens. Donc il y a
eu des ingénieurs agronomes, je je suis
pas compétente là-dedans mais eux
l'était et disaient non là ça marchera
pas mais vous pourriez faire autre
chose. Donc on a leur pas prêté de
l'argent sur quelque chose où on savait
qu'on les envoyait dans le mur. Bon mais
après il y a eu évidemment certains qui
quand est arrivé une des premières
échéances ont dit "Attendez c'est
compliqué là pour nous de rembourser" et
on leur dit "Mais c'est pas grave, vous
nous avez prévenu avant l'échéance donc
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour vous ?
on restructure et cetera et c'est un
exemple formidable de partenariat où on
a et notre obsession était d'être le
plus égalitaire possible. Je me suis
beaucoup battu pour que le questionnaire
parce que les gens devaient présenter
leur projet sur un questionnaire pour
que le questionnaire soit le plus simple
possible pour qu'il soit abordable pour
tous et on avait eu un débat sur aussi
est-ce que ça devait être en langue
régionale ou pas puisque je voulais
vraiment que ce soit très égalitaire
permettant à chacun à chacune à chacun
d'avoir accès à ce crédit. Ça c'est
entre guillemets une activité bancaire
de prêt de microcrédit, de ce qu'on veut
qui marche et je suis très fière d'eux
parce que euh ça marche même pendant le
la période Covid qui est compliquée et
ça continue à marcher et oui, il y a des
situations difficiles mais c'est pas
grave, on aide, on allonge et il y a
très peu d'accidents payants. Donc c'est
ça, c'est ça qui est vertueux et et je
veux vraiment que tout le monde en soit
en soit convaincu. Évidemment, sur les
sujets de spéculation, c'est
complètement autre chose. Revenons,
revenons à nos moutons.
L'État, est-ce que l'État est
démissionnaire ? Est-ce que l'État est
incapable pour réguler
tous ces travers ? Est-ce que le
pantouflage régulier entre
l'administration, la banque, la banque,
l'administration
n'est pas néfaste ? Est-ce que l'État a
des outils pour arrêter cette machine
qui roule à à ton brou ouvert ?
Alors, il y a des outil parce qu'il y a
de multiples organes de régulation
bancaire. Vu
donc oui, on l'a bien vu et en même
temps ils ont aussi pu donner certaines
certaines alertes. Donc, mais oui, il y
a si si il y a mais mais il y a
quelles alertes ? Quand quand on voit
des augmentations en particulier en
Italie de prêts qui étaient commençaient
à être un peu dangereux, c'est non
performing loads, donc c'est prêts qui
ont des sujets. La la Banque d'Italie a
vraiment fait son travail là-dessus en
je je travaillais avec eux à ce
moment-là pour alerter et pour dire
attention là, il y a quelque chose qui
est vraiment dangereux. Donc c'est c'est
c'est ce qui est difficile dans ce genre
de chose. C'est que
monté monté comment elle s'appelle ? Il
y a Monté Pasquen mais c'était pas de
ça. Donc c'était c'était pas le sujet
était plus large que ça. Il commençait à
y avoir quelque chose autour de ces nom
performing loads qui était plus global
que montait pas ce qui dit Sienna mais
et qui pouvait être vraiment dangereux.
Les Italiens ont été la Banque d'Italie
a vraiment été un lanceur d'alerte fort
pour après permettre d'ajuster derrière
et il y a une bonne coopération entre la
Banque d'Italie et les autorités qui
prenaient les qui prenaient les
décisions et qui ont été assez rapides
évidemment aidé par la BCE et par et par
et par Dragy à ce moment-là. C'est c'est
clair. Mais je veux qu'on revienne au à
la question et en effet aux États. C'est
pas toujours aux États de devoir tout
gérer, tout réguler et cetera. Et je
crois que justement en fait, on ne pose
pas le problème tel qu'il doit être.
Quel système bancaire veut-on ? C'est
aussi ça. Est-ce que c'est ce que je
décris ? Évidemment, pas que en
microcrédit, il faut le rendre plus
grand. Est-ce que ce sont ça les banques
que l'on veut et qui après ont les
spécialisations pour des financements
aéronautiques, pour enfin des choses
très très précises pour aider les
entreprises ? Où est-ce qu'on veut des
entités dont on ne sait pas bien ce
qu'elles font ? ce n'est beaucoup de
d'opérations de marché, de choses
extrêmement structurées et cetera et qui
et qui peuvent avoir des profils
lucratifs et où veut-on un mélange des
deux justement ces fameuses
rentabilités, les actionnaires et
cetera, enfin tout ce qu'on a pu mais
posons-nous la question enfin c'est
c'est c'est c'est parce qu' enfin moi
j'ai ma réponse mais je veux dire si
c'est pas ce que c'est
on se pose la question entre nous comme
ça où on fait un référendum on convoque
les directeurs de banque on leur dit bon
maintenant on va ouvrir le coffre et
puis on va voir ce qu'il y a réellement
dedans. Non, je je pense que la seule
manière de gérer le sujet est de faire
que les banques jouent le jeu,
c'est-à-dire que les banque prête à
l'économie et que c'est la manière où
les enfin et c'est le ce que l'État doit
les inciter à faire et que c'est ça
l'corde de rappel plutôt qu'autre chose.
C'est pas un peu du wishful sinking ça ?
Non, pas du tout.
Ça veut dire quoi wishful sinking ?
C'est pas du tout juste comme ça un truc
un peu utopiste et blabla et cetera.
C'est meilleure traduction. que j'ai pu
trouver. Non, c'est non parce que
comment vous voulez autrement trouve ça
va plus vite hein. C'est sinon sinon
sinon quoi ? Sinon on sépare
complètement les deux. OK. Pourquoi ?
Enfin
par exemple mais mais oui peut-être mais
ça n'empêchera pas des activités
spéculatives. Le vrai sujet genre du
genre dark pool chose comme ça. C'est
quoi c'est quoi une dark pool ? du du
genre euh typiquement qui peut faire des
swaps très compliqués avec des états.
Mais ça c'est après ça c'est après autre
chose. Bon,
c'est quoi une dark poule
?
Du je
passons à autre chose peut-être. OK.
Non, mais plus plus important dans le
dans le dans le propos, soit on agrège
les choses, soit on les sépare. Et en
les agrégeant, l'argument en effet qui a
été fait
et celui de dire qu'on pourrait mieux
prêter à l'économie. Donc, si on accepte
cet argument là de ce qu'il,
rendons-les responsable du fait de
prêter plus à l'économie. Et si ce n'est
pas le cas, c'est pas rond ou c'est pas
rond dès le début pour ceux qui ont
cette conviction forte là et cetera.
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire ? En
fait, le vrai sujet pour moi et que
comme sur beaucoup de problématiques, on
ne pose pas les questions de ce que l'on
veut et ensuite après les choses en
découlent de manière extrêmement
automatique et après des comportements
qui sont tout à fait inacceptables
doivent être absolument sanctionnés. Et
on sait très bien qu'il y a des banques
qui ont fait des swaps avec des États ou
des transactions d'ailleurs, pas
forcément que des swaps avec des États
qui ont gagné énormément d'argent. C'est
c'est l'argent qui a été gagné est
quasiment réconciliable à à peu de
choses à peu à peu de choses près en
tout cas dans les ordres de grandeur et
certaines ont pu avoir des amendes euh
mais qui ne sont qui qui ne sont jamais
à la hauteur de ce qui a pu se faire en
plus si on dit que c'est au fil des ans.
Parce que quand on parle d'une
transaction en fait, faut pas oublier
les les 10 avant ou les 100 avant et les
bon voilà. Donc et quelque part ça peut
aussi être un risque, moi j'ai déjà
aussi pu l'entendre ça de bon si on se
fait prendre mais c'est pas c'est pas si
important que ça et cetera. Donc c'est
là où il faut être absolument clair,
absolument irréprochable et il faut que
les États après eux-mêmes et la
discipline de ne pas non plus entrer
dans ce genre de dans ce genre de
spéculation parce que finalement
personne ne forçait la Grèce à faire ses
swaps avec ses maisons euh
anglo-saxonnes. Je je j'en cite pas une
parce que tout le monde l'a fait. Donc
là c'est c'est suffisamment clair.
L'Italie c'était la même chose. Enfin et
certaines régions d'Italie aussi
d'ailleurs plus que l'Italie en tant que
en tant que tel. Voilà. Enfin, après
c'est les ceux qui sont aux commandes de
ces unitésl spécialisées qui sont des
des gens qui sont éminemment compétent
qui doivent après dire "Non, on fait pas
ce genre de chos et oui, peut-être que
ponctuellement je peux gagner un peu
d'argent, mon taux d'intérêt est un peu
un peu plus bas forcément un risque
quelque part. Je suis sur un ton long,
enfin même si moi peut-être je vais pas
travailler euh 30 ans au même poste,
mais je suis quand même sur un ton long
parce que c'est le ton de mon pays et
donc je peux pas leur laisser prendre ce
risque-là ou me dire que je
restructurerai ou me dire que je je sais
pas quoi.
Est-ce que vous connaissez des banques
qui ont maquillé la tête des États pour
leur faire intégrer l'Union européenne ?
Le fameux sujet grec. Euh le
On commence on commence gentiment parce
que vous voulez pas parler des dark pool
donc on va parler de la Grèce.
Non, mais sur les sur l'histoire du du
maquillage des s'agit de ça euh du
maquillage des comptes grecs, il est en
il est en plus beaucoup plus large euh
que que ça.
On vous laisse nous expliquer que ce
soit que ce soit parce que enfin dans
cette si on reprend l'histoire
l'histoire du de ce passage là qui est
absolument tragique mais même avant la
Grèce entre dans l'Union, il y a un peu
trois périodes. Il y a la période
d'entrée dans l'Union européenne où la
Grèce entre à ce moment-là.
Alors, je sais plus si c'est 25 ou 27 %
de de date sur PIB à supposer que ce
soit une grandeur qui soit ça parce
qu'on pourrait discuter de mémoire. Euh
c'est donc ils entrent avec voilà et euh
très rapidement après derrière, mais
quand je dis très rapidement, c'est
quelques années plus tard, il se
retrouve à 95 ans. Donc euh bon enfin
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas rien. Et
finalement dans la période qui marque
l'entrée dans l'euro jusqu'en 2007 qui
est peut-être un peu la deuxème période,
la dette augmente d'une dizaine de pour
enfin plus ou moins et cetera. Et en
effet, le jour où il faut regarder comme
par hasard, on est pile au chiffres.
Voilà.
Et ensuite après derrière se passe que
l'on sait sur les certaines corrections
de dettes qui ont été qui ont été
apportées et ces corrections d'êtes
l'ont été en effet sur des opérations de
swap qui ont été pu être intégrées. Mais
il y avait aussi des choses comme les
arriérés d aux hôpitaux. Enfin, je dire,
c'était
le volume devait être suffisamment
conséquent pour qu'on rajoute quand même
plusieurs choses pour que ça pour que ça
fonctionne.
Bref,
situation d'endettement forte et qui
n'est en fait, et ça c'est trop peu
raconté qui n'est en fait pas lié à un
délire des Grecs qui tout d'un coup
auraient eu des finances publiques où
ils auraient dépensé à Touva et cetera.
L'analyse rigoureuse des chiffres euh et
sans passion, ce qui est difficile pour
moi quand je parle de la Grèce, mais
montre uniquement que c'est au niveau
des dettes privées où là on a fait
absolument n'importe quoi. Et on a fait
n'importe quoi, on sait très bien que
des banques françaises, des banques
allemandes essentiellement, il y avait
aussi d'autres banques européennes à
exactement et ont très largement enfin
pris des participations dans des banques
grecques et aussi très largement étendu
des prêts.
rapporté non
près qui ont évidemment rapporté mais le
sujet là-dessus c'était plutôt c'est
toujours la même chose enfin une
l'économie grecque avait déjà à l'époque
malheureusement
les problèmes qu'ils ont encore avec et
certains ont été accentués certains ont
été corrigés. Le tourisme c'était déjà
un sujet, c'est la surexposition
du PIB au tourisme à ce moment-là. Et
progressivement, il y avait aussi une
désindustrialisation
de la de la Grèce. La Grèce a eu des
pôles d'activité très forts, que ce soit
en chimie, que ce soit aussi dans les
pôles médicaux et et certaines
entreprises aussi qui plutôt
technologiques qui venaient justement gr
de très bons ingénieurs et
progressivement qui après sont sont
partis. Donc ça ça s'est
amoindri. Et alors, on a beaucoup parlé
de des fonctionnaires grecs. Alors, le
fonctionnaire grec est une légende en
soi dans le sens il y a des
caractéristiques qui sont sympathiques.
Mais c'est pas le fonctionnaire grec qui
est responsable de la crise grecque.
C'est une malhonnêteté intellectuelle.
C'est clairement un sujet de crédit
privé qu'on a après fait passer d'une
manière ou d'une autre et par de
multiples
artifices dans de la dette publique qui
après a amené à cette absurdité euh
totale et absolue euh de leur infliger
c'était même pas des potions enfin
c'était des cures d'austérité.
des saigners. Exactement. Euh bien
absolument c'est ça. Des saigners
d'austérité.
L'indifférent général c'est même c'est
encore trop faible sous les
applaudissements de tous ceux qui
voulaient qu'il soient absolument punis.
Et donc
vous voulez faire quoi ? Un exemple ou
il vous il voulait simplement expliquer
que rien n'est au-dessus de la troica.
Alors
rien personne ne peut ne peut contester
la troica. Personne ne peut contester
l'Union européenne. Et c'est c'était
quoi ? C'était les mettre au pas, les
mettre à genou, les les rendre
soumis.
Alors, il y a il y a il y a plusieurs
phases. La première phase et la
déclaration de du premier ministre
Papandre, on s'en souvient tous hein,
annonçant l'entrée du pays sous
programme. Ça c'est la première phase de
je cherche à gérer quelque chose qui est
devenu compliqué pour les banques et il
y a à ce moment-là une défiance. La
Grèce n'arrive plus à emprunter sur les
marchés. n'est aidé par personne à ce
moment-là alors queon aurait pu trouver
d'autres mécanismes mais peu importe
laissons ça de côté.
Attendez, attendez, attendez, j'ai pas
bien compris. C'est une certaine
défiance ou c'était un certain
comportement vautour ?
Non, c'est tout simplement que alors des
marchés ont spéculé là-dessus mais ça à
la limite je laisse de côté. C'est pas
ça qui est important. C'est ce qui est
important parce que j'y reviendrai plus
tard. C'est très important ça le rôle de
la de la BCE. On aurait pu aussi à ce
moment-là déjà penser que il y avait une
partie de la dette qui pouvait être
achetée d'une manière ou d'une autre.
Voyez ce que je veux dire ? faire des
choses qui maintenant nous semblent.
Enfin, maintenant notre sujet c'est ah
bon, ils en ont racheté que là c'est là
on était même pas au concept du rachat,
voyez ce que je veux dire ? qu'on a
quand même évolué dans la manière de
regarder les choses. Donc il y a cette
première ces premiers programmes, ces
mesures en effet d'austérité, des
nonsens aussi comme typiquement demander
de privatiser. Alors déjà qui a passé un
jour en Grèce comprend que la
bureaucratie grecque rend les choses un
peu compliquées quand on veut privatiser
des choses rapidement. Euh mais tant
mieux qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
privatisé euh parce que là aussi
des aéroports ou des ports là ou des
îles ?
Non euh non les les îles ça c'est autre
chose. C'était quasiment même les
vendres hein. Ça donc c'était ça c'était
ça c'était encore pire non c'est tout
simplement c'était l'eau par exemple la
compagnie d'eau, la compagnie
d'électricité enfin c'était c'était tout
ça. Donc vous avez un pays dont on vous
dit qu'il est au bord de la faillite et
le remède c'est faut privatiser. Bah
bizarrement il y a pas beaucoup
d'investisseurs qui vont acheter ça à un
prix extrêmement élevé.
Est-ce que vous avez lu le bouquin ?
C'est de mémoire chronique d'un assassin
économique.
Non, j'ai pas lu. J'en ai entendu
parler. Je confesse ne pas l'avoir lu.
Je vous absou
mais je le dirai. Mais ce qui est très
important dans cette histoire grecque,
c'est qu'il y a cette phase qu'on décrit
là et puis il y a l'arrivée de Cypras
parce que ça ça change tout.
Et donc moi, j'ai j'ai l'honneur
d'intervenir à ces côtés et ça reste ça
restera comme une des plus belles
périodes de ma vie parce que je me suis
senti utile, même si je suis je défends
ce qu'on a fait mais je suis en colère
qu'on nit pas pu faire plus
et je considère qu'il faut qu'on qu'il
faut que quelque part on se batte et on
continue à se battre pour cette pour
cette cause. Mais laissons ça de de côté
un instant. Si press arrive au pouvoir.
Alors, on a on a tout écrit hein, qu'il
est incompétent que enfin bon
mais toute la presse enfin je veux dire
moi je j'ai très peu de souvenirs d'une
presse favorable.
Euh et il n'était pas aidé, il est vrai,
par le fait que au début de son mandat,
il parle assez mal anglais. Quand moi je
travaille avec lui en 2016, il fait
toutes ses confalles avec la chanolière
ou avec qui d'autre en anglais sans
interprète. Donc il a aussi une capacité
d'apprendre vite mais évidemment les
gens et puis le cette séance absolument
abominable au Parlement européen dans
lequel il est complètement ridiculisé
aussi sur des sujets de de langue ce qui
est particulièrement frustrant en plus
quand on connaît c'est
surtout particulièrement humiliant
non mais c'est même c'est même plus que
que que c'était humiliant pour lui et
pour son pays qui représentait parce que
voilà et et c'est surtout complètement
aussi frust je je veux dire le mot
frustrant parce que c'est un orateur
exceptionnel. Son grec est un délice et
je et donc que cet homme-là qui est
vraiment un homme de mots n'ait pas pu
se défendre ou proprement se défendre
était quelque chose d'en plus
complètement paradoxal. Mais il arrive
au pouvoir et à ce moment-là parce que
beaucoup a été écrit et il y a il y a
finalement beaucoup de choses qui sont
pas forcément exactes qui ont été qui
ont été écrits. Il y a deux camps hein
enfin il y a deux camps. Il y a plein de
camps dans ce dans ce gouvernement.
Déjà, c'est un gouvernement de
coalition, tout le monde s'en souvient
pas mais c'est un gouvernement de
coalition. Et même au sein de Syriza,
tout le monde n'est pas d'accord hein.
Il y a ceux qui sont plutôt sur une
ligne grexit, il y a ceux qui sont
plutôt sur une ligne on reste euh mais
on va les faire plier. Enfin, on étant
la troica et cetera. Donc en fait, on
aura ça à nos conditions sur
les Allemands quoi.
Oui, parce que c'est très frontal en
effet par rapport à l'Allemagne. C'est
en effet assez personnifié.
Vu adulte in the room.
Oui. Que j'ai alors même si Costavra est
un de vraiment des personnes pour
lesquelles j'ai le plus profond respect
et que j'ai adoré j'ai adoré tous ces
films cas en particulier quelque chose
qui enfin m'avait m'avait m'avait
bouleversé. Là c'est le seul film avec
lequel je suis en profond désaccord avec
lui et même j'ai été très heurtée de ce
film que j'ai vu jusqu'au bout parce que
je respecte son son œuvre. Il ne le
héros dans de cette crise sont le peuple
grec.
Et je ne supporte pas le fait que
quelqu'un qui qu' qu'il quel qu'il soit
là. Ouioui mais je vais je vais venir se
mettre en avant
dans une crise pareille ça n'existe pas
et la réalité alors moi j'interviens
auprès de Cypras une fois que qu'on va
refaire est parti donc on ne sait pas on
n pas travaillé ensemble je le dis c'est
important parce que je ne me permettrai
pas de juger quelqu'un que en fait je ne
connais pas connais ça bien
ce que ce que je ce que je ce que par
contre je me permets de de dire c'est
que je ne supporte pas à titre personnel
les gens qui se mettent en avant sur une
situation situation de crise qui le font
de manière extrêmement égotique et qui
ne jouent pas le collectif. Et moi ce
que nous avons fait et qui est imparfait
et encore une fois nous tous on sait que
c'est imparfait mais on a fait en
équipe, on l'a fait derrière un chef qui
était Alexis Cipras. J'ai pas toujours
été d'accord avec les décisions qu'il a
pris il y a une fois dans en 3 ans de
coopération où je lui ai dit Alexis si
tu prends cette décision là je ne peux
pas te suivre parce que ça c'est trop
orthogonal avec moi. Je te trouverai
quelqu'un qui me remplacera et cetera
parce queil s'agit pas d'être pratiqué
la terre brûée mais je ne peux pas te
suivre. On a discuté toute la nuit, on
s'est quitté, ça devait être 5h, 5h30 du
du matin et la décision devait être
prise pour 7h. Enfin, je veux dire, on
avait voilà et j'ai pensé qu'il allait
qu'il allait pas suivre ce que je ce que
j'avais recommandé et il a rappelé en
disant "OK, je te je te suis." Bon, mais
sinon, je ça c'était vraiment trop
porte. Sinon, on a tous
été derrière le chef ou derrière la
majorité ? Parce que là aussi pareil, il
y a des décisions où on votait, enfin on
votait, on donnait notre avis à main
levée dans le groupe de gens qui
prenaient les décisions et c'était la
voix de la majorité. Moi généralement,
j'étais d'accord. Il y a eu de rares cas
où j'étais pas d'accord mais j'ai suivi
la majorité et j'ai défendu ça, j'espère
avec autant de passion, même si c'était
pas mon avis que que quand c'était mon
avis. Mais donc je ce film qui met en
lumière et c'est important
ce ces mascarades
de débat qui pouvaient de temps en temps
se passer puisque tout était prédécidé
avant où on savait à quel résultat on
voulait obtenir ou
quelle sauce vous vouliez les manger
si vous voulez en effet ça le mérite de
montrer ça ça c'est pour ça que je rends
hommage à cette partie là du film. Sur
le reste, Gavra a fait des choix qui
sont pas les miens. C'est-à-dire, il a
mis pour moi beaucoup trop en avant un
homme et pas assez son peuple et le
peuple, même si il dédit le film et
cetera. J'ai bien j'ai bien entendu ça.
Il fait il rend des des certains
personnages beaucoup trop sympathiques
par rapport à la réalité.
Comme qui ? Non, mais comme à peu près
tous quelque part parce que et pile est
très maniquéin avec certaines personnes
qui faisaient partie de l'équipe de
négociation grecque qui ont été beaucoup
plus courageux que ça. Et c'est trop
maniquin et c'est j'aime pas ça parce
que parce que les choses étaient en fait
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus compliquées
que ça. Mais par contre ce qui ne
l'était pas et ce qui était très clair,
d'où la responsabilité aussi de
Varoufakis de manière claire. Et
Varofaki c'est un excellent économiste.
N'importe qui a étudié l'économie, qui
se préoccupe de ces questions-là, le
respecte, quel que soit ce qu'ils
peuvent dire euh derrière.
Et en plus, il est cool et il a pas
d'ego.
Il a aucun ego, il est hyper cool. Non,
mais tout le monde respecte sa pensée.
Il est extrêmement articulé, il est
extrêmement précis. Tout le monde le
dit. Donc c'est ça, c'est pas la
question.
Mais quand on a une responsabilité
historique, parce que c'était ça la
responsabilité historique, c'était
d'essayer d'infléchir
l'inacceptable.
Donc c'était une mission quasi
impossible bien sûr, sauf que devant une
mission quasi impossible, vous vous
donnez au moins les chances d'y arriver.
Ça veut dire que vous êtes extrêmement
précis techniquement. Ça veut dire que
vous avez des équipes de com. Vous me
vous me comprenez quand je dis ça.
C'està-dire vous avez des relais. C'est
ça que je veux dire par équipe de com.
Non non des relais, des vrais relais qui
vous êtes pas le seul à parler. Vous
vous avez des gens que ce soit en Grèce,
aux États-Unis qui
une stratégie quoi.
Oui, une stratégie, quelque chose qui
est construit et cetera et et vous y
allez fort. Vous y allez fort. Et il y a
pas trois solutions. Il y a ce qu'on
propose et il y a évidemment si ça se
fait pas derrière des plans de des plans
de secours. Bon et ça s'est pas
réellement passé comme ça parce que et
il y a des courriers qui en témoignent,
il y avait la volonté
de quelque part faire que prace. Je
parle pas pour faiss parle de je parle
de de de certains des dirigeants
européens ou des instances européennes.
Il y avait la volonté de faire que
Cipras ne s'en sorte pas parce que il
représentait enfin l'extrême gauche, le
communisme. Enfin franchement, on a pu
lire des choses, on a pu entendre des
choses qui étaient complètement folles
comme si d'extrême gauche était une
insulte, comme si communist enfin tout
ça déjà était complètement sorti de son
contexte. C'est quelqu'un qui a une
pensée extrêmement articulée et tout
simplement c'était le leader que les
Grecs avaient choisi pour eux-même. Donc
en ça méritait euh le respect. Enfin le
il y avait même pas à questionner ce
qu'il pouvait penser ou quoi.
Le même respect pour le peuple américain
quand il élit Donald Trump.
J'ai j'ai pardon.
Vous avez le même respect quand le
peuple américain élit Donald Trump ?
Alors moi j'ai un respect mais alors
absolument profond pour la démocratie.
Donc mais alors mais mais même si le
choix ne me convient pas. Donc c'est
tout le monde sait que je suis plutôt à
gauche. Donc j'ai un respect vraiment
profond pour la démocratie.
Ça veut dire que non. C'est ça.
Bah est-il à gauche ? C'est vous qui
savez. J'ai pas l'impression
j'ai pas j'ai pas l'impression.
Non, j'ai j'ai
pour mais pour revenir sur Cras, il a il
a et c'est et c'est le drame du début,
il arrive au pouvoir. En effet, c'est
vrai quand on dit il est inexpérimenté,
j'aime pas ce mot parce que c'est un
homme politique qui a énormément de
charisme et qui s'est entraîné, qui est
un leader. il connaît intimement son
pays, il connaît intimement les
formations de décision, les stratégies
et cetera. Il est moins expérimenté sur
la scène internationale. Bien sûr, bien
sûr, c'est tout à fait vrai, mais comme
plein d'autres gens.
Et toutes les mécanismes se mettent en
œuvre pour, comme je le disais, essayer
de de le bloquer, enfin essayer de
essayer de l'empêcher.
Éviter en fait que le le courant de
gauche se propage en Europe.
Oui, c'était comme ça que c'était
formulé et c'est mais mais ce qui ce qui
pour moi est un truc qui m'a toujours
enfin interpellé, comment peut-on
vouloir quelque chose qui est en fait la
enfin le contraire de la volonté du
peuple ? Enfin, c'est c'est et c'est
d'ailleurs après
ça vous interpelle, vous avez toujours
pas trouvé la réponse.
Bah, j'ai j'ai mes propres j'ai mes
propres réponses, mais c'est pas pour ça
que je l'accepte en fait. Mon sujet la
réponse,
mais là, il y avait clairement des
intérêts qui allaient contre le vote qui
s'était produit. C c'est évident.
Mais l'intérêt de de gens de vouloir
promouvoir ce que l'on pensait à ce
moment-là être la norme qui était une
doctrine d'austérité. Parce que là
aussi, c'est assez amusant quand même de
voir des pensées fluctuantes parce que
les mêmes qui vous expliquaient que
l'austérité, il y avait que ça se sont
après déporté pour expliquer que
maintenant on dépense des enf même plus
compter les milliards qu'on dépense. Bon
mais et tout ça a été théorisé parce que
enfin c'est c'est quelque chose de de
connu mais on il y a eu des des des
universitaires américains. On s'est
après rendu compte que leur recherche
était fausse. d'ailleurs un jeune d'une
université
un peu plus un peu plus au nord non
pardon un peu plus au sud de leur
université qui en regardant un peu les
recherches et le fameux résultat qui
disait que en dessus d'un certain niveau
de dette sur PIB euh les pays entraient
entraient en récession bah cet étudiant
a montré que en fait c'était tout à fait
faux et c'était faux à plusieurs titres
un parce qu'il y avait une erreur dans
l'Excel donc ça quand il était aller
voir ses mtres de test pour dire il y a
une erreur, ils m'ont dit écoute, tu vas
être extrêmement gentil, c'est quand
même des somités, donc déjà refais-toi
tes calcul. Oui, oui, mais moi je les ai
refait. Bon, et au-delà de ça, il y
avait tout un biais comme la plupart du
temps, hein, c'est ce qu'on beaucoup
trop de gens font avec les chiffres.
Vous sélectionnez certaines choses, vous
prenez pas certains pays et donc ça vous
fait dire des choses qui ne vont mais au
nom de par exemple ces papiers de
recherche là qui ont été beaucoup
utilisés, on a après imposé des choses
qui n'avaient absolument aucun sens.
Bon, mais ce qui est intéressant en fait
comme quoi
ah ben comme c'est politiques
d'austérité, enfin je veux dire, il y a
il y a pas il y a pas enfin il y a très
peu de mesures
qui avait un sens pour la Grèce.
Ça a peut-être pas de sens pour vous
mais ça a forcément un sens pour les
gens qui le demandaient. Non,
très franchement, je me suis là sur le
coup, je me suis vraiment beaucoup posé
la question parce que c'était un non
sens économique depuis le début. Mais
un sens politique peut-être. Non, non,
mais non, mais un non économique, Oui,
mais euh enfin au bout d'un moment, vous
pouvez pas juste recommander des choses
qui ne marchent absolument pas pour euh
détruire un peuple. Enfin, il il y a il
y a quand même une partie dans
l'histoire où il y a certainement une
non compréhension de certaines choses.
Je je j'explique mon propos. Euclist
Tacalotos, donc qui a remplacé
Varofais a je trouve la meilleure des
formules là-dessus. Il dit dans toutes
les mesures qu'on nous a présenté,
imposé et cetera, en fait, il y avait
celle qui était absolument inacceptable
et qu'on a pas faites et on les a pas
faites et on avait des mécanismes pour
pas les faire. On disait "Oui, oui, on
le fait et puis voilà." il y avait ceux
euh queon allait faire de toute manière
parce que certaines étaient dans le
programme, c'était tout simplement des
réformes structurelles où il y avait des
dysfonctionnement enfin je veux dire
donc ça évidemment enfin il y avait des
choses à réparer et puis il y avait le
milieu qui était le plus compliqué où il
fallait faire le tri de ce qui était bon
ce qui était pas bon et surtout il
fallait orienter amender pour faire que
ce soit bon voilà et on a essayé de de
de travailler comme ça mais
sur et ça c'est aussi un des souvenirs
extrêmement extrêmement fort sur la
Grèce. Là, on se projette un peu un peu
plus tard. C'est c'est au début de
l'année, enfin c'est les discussions
sont 2018-29, fin d'année 2018-29.
Moi, j'ai le souvenir fort et révolté
de discussions où on voulait redonner un
mois de retraite puisqu'on avait les
moyens à ce moment-là de le de le faire.
Évidemment, on a une opposition forte de
plusieurs membres de la Troy qui nous
disent "Mais non, vous recommencez à
dépenser et cetera." Et en fait, on dit
"Ben déjà un, on nous a imposé un
excédent primaire
3,5 hein dans cette période là." Donc
qui n'a aucun sens. Vous regardez tous
les pays du monde, trouvez-moi celui qui
sur longue période a 3,5 d'excéd prière.
Donc déjà un non sens économique pour
commencer.
Mais quelque part, les réformes qui qui
étaient faites étaient des chocs tels
qu'en fait on n jamais été à 3,5, on
était à 4,2 4,3.
Donc on était dans un truc d'une
inefficacité folle qui consistait à ce
que à la fin de l'année, enfin on
pilotait nos chiffres. Donc allez, en
septembre, on savait qu'il y avait de
l'argent entre guillemets en trop parce
qu'on avait on nous avait trop fait
couper dans les dépense et qu'il fallait
qu'on redistribue. Ça c'est la manière
parfaite de gérer un état. Ça c'est ce
qu'on vous apprend en première leçon.
Donc absurdité totale. Donc notre propos
était de dire bon, sachant que là vous
venez quand même de nous faire faire
n'importe quoi. Bon peut-être que sur
cette partie-là et alors pour aussi
mettre des ordres de grandeur parce que
je crois qu'on les a tous perdus pour la
Grèce cette partie-là donc le delta que
je mentionne entre entre K2 43 et et le
35 c'est un milliard hein. Donc
c'est beaucoup d'argent mais par rapport
aux 100 milliards et autres dont on
parle actuellement, c'est très très peu.
Et donc c'est un choix qui est très
difficile à faire quand on est aux
responsabilités parce que est-ce que on
le distribue à une catégorie, est-ce
qu'on le distribue à plusieurs
catégories ? Enfin, qu'est-ce qu'on fait
? Parce que avec le risque de si on
soupre trop, de n'avoir finalement aucun
effet. Et donc à ce moment-là, on a ce
débat de dire bah donc on va redonner le
13e mois. Et on a dû pendant plusieurs
mois se battre pour avoir l'autorisation
de faire ça alors que c'était de
l'argent qui évidemment nous appartenait
parce qu'on nous expliquait que on
favorisait les retraités par rapport au
aux actifs, que c'était déjà de la
dépense en plus et cetera. Alors qu'on
leur expliquait mais en fait la famille
grecque, si vous saviez ce qu'est une
famille grecque, en fait ils vivent
entre guillemets tous ensemble et donc
les grands-parents ou les arrières-
grands-parents qui vont recevoir,
ils ont pas trop le choix he
c'est aussi quelque chose de culturel et
donc les arrières-grands-parents, les
grands-parents vont tout de suite
redonner l'argent aux enfants,
petits-enfants et cetera et donc ça va
être un boost à la consommation et c'est
pour ça qu'on défend cette mesure. et le
fait même un qu'on ait dû argumenter ce
qui est juste fou parce que c'est
vraiment la traduction de la perte de
souveraineté. Ensuite qu'on ait dû
justifier quelque chose ou quand même
enfin il y avait plusieurs économistes
compétents autour de la table donc là
aussi pareil au bout d'un moment bon et
ensuite après que ça ait pris du temps
pour pouvoir le mettre en œuvre était
quelque chose d'éminemment choquant.
Merci pour ce petit résumé. On va passer
à des choses un peu plus piquantes.
Euh, on a fait dimanche une une
interview de Pierre Laroutourou qui nous
fait une petite greffe de la fin. Euh
là, il est à 9 jours
et parce que le il est rapporteur du
budget européen et il souhaiterait que
on taxe la spéculation. Hm
hm.
Pourquoi ça se fait pas ? Ça fait des
décennies qu'on entend ça. Pourquoi ça
se fait pas ? Pourquoi les banques,
certaines banques françaises se sentent
menacées par cette proposition là ?
Pourquoi on est obligé d'avoir le
rapporteur du budget européen qui est
obligé de faire une greffe de la fin
dans le Parlement ?
Je crois que vous avez raison de
souligner que c'est un débat qui est
très très vieux et alors après les gens
l'ont appelé taxine, les gens l'ont
appelé taxe sur les transactions
financières, enfin bon en tout cas ce
type de de taxe là. Alors, l'argument
principal qui est présenté par ceux qui
s'opposent euh est de dire ça va nuire à
la compétitivité
de euh la place de Paris ou la place de
je sais pas quoi et cetera.
Par rapport à ça, je crois que ça
pouvait être des arguments
où c'était peut-être plus difficile de
trouver un consensus pour dire que ça
n'avait pas de sens que maintenant
dit autrement.
Ce genre de taxe est évidemment
nécessaire
après la manière dont c'est structurer
que les spécialistes le disent. Pourquoi
c'est nécessaire ? On voit bien qu'il y
a plusieurs choses qui doivent être
financées. Je m'explique. Un pays doit
financer certains de ses besoins, mais
ça va jusqu'à la mairie qui doit
financer ses besoins. Enfin, c'est donc
c'est la chaîne du pays. Ensuite, après,
si on a un projet européen ou quel qu'il
soit d'ailleurs de n'importe quelle zone
he c'est la même chose, et bien il y a
doit des financements pour cette zone
qui après fait soit des choses en
transversal, soit redescend certains des
certains des des montants. Et puis a ce
que moi j'appelle enf je suis pas la
seule ce qu'on appelle les communs et
donc qui sont le bah le commun ou ce qui
nous appartient tous et dans lequel
après on peut discuter ce qu'on met
évidemment tout le monde met
l'environnement pense qu'il faudrait
aussi mettre la santé enfin il y a il y
a des débats sur
l'hôpital et les profs g pas
non non tout à fait alors après encore
une fois là-dessus attention
justice
bien sûr et on peut aussi dire la
sécurité enfin je c'est on peut rajouter
ça attention à ça et parce qu' c'est
vraiment plusieurs niveaux Ce que je
veux dire par là, c'est que le
financement des communs
doit évidemment se faire par exemple
pour chercher un vaccin si on si on si
on parle de ça. Et là, tous les pays en
effet devraient financer, trouver,
chercher chercher un vaccin. Après le
financement, si on parle de la France ou
un autre pays, peu importe, de
l'hôpital,
de l'école évidemment qui sont
évidemment des choses fondamentales,
pour moi c'est attention, c'est du
ressort national ce que je veux dire par
là. Et ça veut pas dire qu'il y a pas
des correspondances. Ce que je veux dire
par là, c'est que un pays qui est bien
géré et qui est en cohérence avec
lui-même, donc a priori avec des
individus qui sont en cohérence avec
eux-mêmes, donc a priori heureux, on
espère, c'est un pays qui sait dire
"J'ai une, deux ou trois priorités."
Typiquement, en effet, celle qu'on vient
de dire euh là. Et ça, ça veut dire si
on dit que l'éducation est prioritaire,
je crois qu'il y a un effet consensus
là-dessus, les moyens doivent être mis
pour que l'éducation soit vraiment
prioritaire. Mais moyens, ça veut dire
bien sûr moyen financier, évidemment la
question ne se pose pas. Moyen humain
aussi. Ça veut dire que si on a je suis
pas spécialiste d'éducation mais il est
évident qu'une classe de 35, c'est pas
la même chose qu'une classe de 15 ou
qu'une classe de 13. Bon donc c'est ça
et c'est aussi la valorisation
revalorisation du statut de prof enfin
d'enseignant enfin de d'instituteur et
dans lequel la place dans la société de
l'institute du prof de est
en adéquation avec ce que l'on dit de
l'importance de l'école. Mais si on on
peut pas faire l'un sans faire l'autre,
enfin il est important de tout faire.
Mais oui, évidemment quand vous avez et
c'est et c'est connu en Europe, la
France et le pays qui paye le moins bien
ses jeunes profs puis après les les
courbes sont peuvent être différentes.
Mais mais bien sûr aussi et qui n'a et
qui
et qui avait une définition aussi par
rapport à ces chercheurs. Si on parle
par exemple de la médecine, il y avait
enfin les professeurs devaient chercher,
soigner, enseigner, enfin bon. Mais mais
donc là aussi donnons les bons
écosystèmes pour que ces choses-là son
soient possibles. Mais
trop tard,
mais il n'est jamais trop tard. C'est il
faut il n'est jamais trop tard. Par
contre, il faut être lucide, très lucide
sur où sont les différentes failles, sur
l'urgence en effet, parce que là, je
vous rejoint tout à fait, et sur le fait
que les crises sont souvent des
accélérateurs
de choses beaucoup plus profondes. Il y
a beaucoup de choses qu'on peut ne pas
voir, soit parce qu'on choisit de pas
les voir, soit parce que elles sont
moins faciles à voir. En temps de crise,
tout se voit. Tout se voit. Je crois
qu'on en a tous
tout ça.
Je tout se voit et je crois qu'on en a
fait l'expérience. Et donc il faut qu'on
se rende compte et qu'on accepte nos
fragilités mais en même temps dire
fragilité ne veut pas dire que on ne
doit pas voir quels sont nos atouts
parce que sinon c'est absolument trop
manqué. Mais par contre de voir
l'urgence d'agir et de restructurer
certaines choses. Mais quand on y
réfléchit un peu, c'est finalement assez
normal. On a sous-investi dans la
plupart de ces domaines, mais pas
pendant un an, pendant des décennies. On
a fait des choix dans lequel on disait
il faut couper, faut couper, faut bon.
Et
c'est qui ? Je crois que beaucoup il est
censé être des classes politiques. Enfin
moi je sais pas distinguer
restructurer la politique.
En tout cas on doit peut-être en tout
cas on doit avoir au pouvoir me
semble-t-il des dirigeants qui sont
capables et de poser les questions. Vous
savez moi il y a un cas qui m'a qui m'a
toujours beaucoup intéressé c'est le cas
de Florenge.
Le cas de
Floreng. Pourquoi ? Parce que
al Florange licencié rachat, on
explique, je laisse expliquer tout à
fait. Florange est un cas dans lesquels
on avait une entreprise indienne mital
qui
avait racheté
Arcelor. Donc déjà, on commence si on
voulait faire toute la chaîne, à ce
moment-là, il faudrait il aurait fallu
s'interroger et on ne l'a pas fait
sur
Je peux vous couper ? Oui, bien sûr.
Peux
le Je trouve que vous êtes vraiment très
gentil à dire on ne l'a pas fait. Est-ce
que vous pensez pas par exemple pour
Alstom parce queon
des fois on dit "Ah ben on l'a pas fait
ou on a pas assez réfléchi". Est-ce que
vous pensez pas qu'il y a quand même des
gens qui ont un intérêt à brader les
bijoux de famille français ?
Quand Arnaud Montbourg dit pour pour
général Alstom ou
tout Paris était acheté.
On va on va je comprends l'intérêt des
formules manicaines. Les choses sont
souvent plus compliquées que ça. J'y
reviens. On va parler d'om parce c'est
important.
Je je je dis et je maintiendrai toujours
que dans au cas de mital et je je
connais bien le dossier, la chose n'a
pas été posée comme elle devait être
posée. Et ça s'est aussi matérialisé sur
Florence. Personne n'a vraiment voulu
réfléchir au côté stratégique ou pas
stratégique de cette de cette industrie.
Et la réalité c'est qu'il y a une erreur
fondamentale qui a été faite en pensant
que c'était une industrie du passé. Non
mais c'était ce qui se disait. Reprenons
les choses à l'époque, ce qui était une
erreur stratégique. Ben ce qui
je veux vous l'entendre le dire. Non,
non, mais tant de tant les dirigeants
d'ailleurs forcément de d'Arcelor que
certains des politiques et certains non
mais tout le monde, il y avait consensus
mais mais Bercy peut-être Bercy enfin ce
que je veux dire par là sur Ber il y a
c'est pas tant le sujet de Bery, c'est
le sujet de tout le monde franchement il
y a pas un plus qu'un autre c'est ce
évidemment il y a un état actionnaire
donc c'est l'état enfin je veux dire
donc qui qui se matérialise par Bercy
très bien mais pas plus que certains des
dirigeants d'Arscor pas plus que
d'autres gens qui dont c'est aussi quand
même le métier de poser ce type de
question. Tout le monde a vu et a a
pensé que cette industrie là, que cette
branche là d'activité était une branche
du passé. Non mais au bout d'un moment,
faut dire que il peut y avoir eu des
erreurs de diagnostic, de compréhension,
d'anticipation,
ce qui est quand même juste le cas en
fait hein. Bon donc c'est de ça dont on
parle
la remise en question la conduite
introspective
et ben justement elle est pas beaucoup
faite. Donc donc c'est donc c'est ça le
sujet mais c'est ça c'est c'est ça ce
dont on est en train de parler. Mais par
contre Florange encore une fois c'est
très important parce que donc on arrive
à ce à ce sujet Florange et tout d'un
coup il faut fermer Florange parce que
c'est c'est plus productif et donc bon
et en fait on n' pas posé la question du
tout de la manière dont elle devait être
posée parce que c'était très simple soit
Florange était stratégique parce que
l'industrie était stratégique parce que
le site était stratégique et dans ces
cas-là il fallait pas se lancer dans un
débat de nationalisation et de grands
mots et cetera il fallait nationaliser
Mais mais sans hésiter. C'était la chose
à faire. C'était la chose cohérente. En
fait le sujet c'est le manque de
cohérence. C'est stratégique
nationalisé. C'est pas stratégique,
c'est pas agréable pour les gens qui
travaillent à Florange. Mais ils doivent
et l'État doit les leur dire la vérité.
Dire que le site doit fermer, que ils
sont accompagnés. Et accompagnés, ça
veut pas dire je te donne un chèque et
je me fous de toi en fait. Parce que ils
savent très on sait très bien que les
gens vont avoir beaucoup de mal à
retrouver du travail. hein. Donc on leur
dit voilà ce qu'on vous propose en terme
de formation. Et là aussi c'est pas des
formations qui servent à rien, c'est des
formations qui après permettent de
retrouver un travail et donc on fait des
vrais programmes d'accompagnement pour
qu'ils puissent retrouver derrière
leur place dans un groupe, une société,
peu importe ce que c'est après derrière
et qui leur et qui leur convient. Mais
c'était un arbre de choix et le problème
n'a pas été posé comme ça. C'est dès
qu'on a dit le mot nationalisation, il y
a des gens qui ont dit "Oh, c'est le
retour de je sais pas quoi d'ailleurs,
du communiste, du socialisme, on sait
même pas de quoi était le retour." C'est
pas la question. Les Américains font ça
tous les jours quand ils ont besoin de
le faire. C'est stratégique, c'est pas
stratégique. Et évidemment que c'est un
drame terrible pour les gens dont
l'usine don dont l'usine ferme, c'est
pas la question, mais la responsabilité
des gens, c'est de leur dire que c'est
ça ce qui se passe et c'est de pas les
laisser évidemment seul. et c'est de
surtout pas leur faire croire qu'ils
vont être accompagnés alors qu'ils vont
pas l'être. Ça c'est encore pire que
tout. Et donc ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui me qui me qui me tient à cœur
parce que je considère que c'est
beaucoup un des problèmes de l'époque.
L'éducation est important. la chaîne
doit suivre mais la chaîne autour de ce
que j'ai dit sur les sur les trois blocs
la santé est importante, même chose. Et
après, il y a des idées enfin Philippe
Dust Blazi a par exemple une idée qui
est qui est intéressante sur le fait de
dire et et il sait de de quoi il parle
qui est de dire des hôpitaux
généralistes, des hôpitaux spécialisés
qui sont en même temps des unités de
recherche. Je ne suis pas une
spécialiste de la santé, cette idée me
semble attirante, elle devrait être
débattue évidemment mais faisons-le,
faisons-le. Même chose sur la justice et
cetera.
Quel est le problème de ça ? Quel est le
problème ? Le problème c'est une vision
de stratège
d'anticipation.
Oui. Oui. Ça c'est un des
qui sont à la barre qui est à la barre
de la stratégie du plan à 30 ans de la
vision long terme de la vision de la
France qui
Mais vous savez très bien qu'on a pas eu
ça depuis un moment donc on a abandonné
le plan. Enfin ça c'est c'est un fait.
C'est c'est bien, c'est pas bien.
Évidemment que c'est idiot parce que
parce que il est évident qu'il doit y
avoir trois phases et et et clairement
ces trois phases c'est et d'ailleurs
faire et et un dirigeant et les gens que
moi je conseille doivent être et c'est
ça qui est pas simple et qu'il faut
savoir faire. Il faut être dans
l'immédiat, il faut être en même temps
dans le moyen terme, il faut être dans
le long terme. Et il y a un petit groupe
de personnes qui doit vous faire la
synthèse.
Mais après, vous avez plus ou moins des
équipes différentes évidemment qui
doivent pas faire des choses
contradictoires sinon vous allez pas y
arriver mais vous pouvez pas. C'est pour
ça que Macron a a
privatisé ou du moins
faire entrer le le privé au qu d'orsais
parce que ils avaient pas de vision long
terme. Ils étaient complètement
tétanisés, ils étaient vieillissants,
ils faisaient rien ou c'était Nous on a
une expression, je suis désolé, je vais
peut-être vous
c'est un peu vulgaire, c'est pas de
couille, pas d'embrouille.
C'est ça. Est-ce qu'on se retrouve par
exemple la stratégie de Bery ? pas de
couille, pas d'embrouille, on fait sa
petite carrière, on est tranquille puis
la maison paye bien, le quedal, c'est à
peu près la même chose. Est-ce que c'est
pour ça que vous avez monté votre
cabinet pour conseiller les États ?
Est-ce que c'est une forme de hack de se
dire voilà, je vais faire je vais faire
croire que je suis une adepte du
consensus mou, mais je suis très très
intelligente ou ça tiens et je vais
essayer de faire changer la vie du pays
ou essayer de mettre un peu plus de
bonté dans la finance. C'est est-ce que
c'est ça
la raison de GSA ? Elle naî de
l'expérience grecque
pardon Global Sverine Advisory.
Elle né de l'expérience grecque
du fait que j'ai eu l'intime conviction
qu'on pouvait pas juste conseiller un
état sur sa dette qui était à ce
moment-là ce que je faisais
principalement qu'il fallait aussi
évidemment aider sur la fiscalité sur
l'économie mais évidemment aussi sur
parce qu'il y avait des réformes en
cours sur la justice enfin évidemment
sur d'autres choses aussi après derrière
et là c'est vraiment pas du tout mes
domaines de compétence donc c'était
travailler avec d'autres pour pour ça et
que on arrive à faire quelque chose
qu'avec avec de la cohérence et c'est ce
qui manque le plus. parler du qu d'oret
mais la réalité c'est que un pays
évidemment doit avoir une diplomatie qui
est basée sur son histoire sur certaines
Non non mais évidemment enfin mais non
mais c'est très important
c'est le cas c'est le cas à l'heure
actuelle
c'est très important
on a que l'odeur de laftaline et la et
la hauteur des moquêtes là en ce moment
non
non non mais attendez c'est c'est très
important sur les sujets d'histoire
parce qu'en fait souvent les les gens ne
se comprennent pas tout simplement parce
qu'ils ne comprennent pas l'histoire de
l'autre enfin je crois qu'on a quand
même beaucoup d'exemples récent aussi
qui nous le qui nous le montre de temps
en temps. Moi je c'est je prends je
prends cet exemple là parce que des
choses me frappaient. Il y avait
beaucoup de commentairire qui était fait
sur l'Autriche. Bon et je défends pas
l'Autriche, c'est pas la question mais
j'avais juste rappelé que en fait bah
viennent il y a pas si longtemps ils
avaient faim. Donc c'est c'est juste
vrai. C'est juste un fait. Donc, il y a
certains choses qui nous semblent
particulières, c'est-à-dire cette espèce
du culte du paysan euh parce que il y a
un peu un un peu un côté un côté comme
ça ou un rôle fort donné à des
fonctionnaires enf qui s'explique par
beaucoup de choses de l'histoire. Et je
dis pas c'est bien, c'est mal, c'est pas
ça. C'est pour se comprendre, faut se
connaître et faut pouvoir dialoguer
ensemble. Donc mais la diplomatie
actuellement, enfin c'est pas juste
actuellement de tout temps, la
diplomatie ne va jamais sans un volet
économique parce qu'il y a des relations
commerci justement voilà des relations
commerciales
et vous avez un problème de cohérence
quand il y a pas le capital humain enfin
quand il y a pas les axes diplomatiques
qui sont fixés le capital humain qui est
qui est mis pour ça, donc des
coopérants, enfin des euh peu importe la
forme que ça prend, enfin un soft erreur
qui est qui est mis en œuvre et ensuite
après derrière des liens économiques
cohérents. Si un pays est un pays amis
ou avec lequel vous voulez développer
des liens, et ben il faut regarder les
liens dans toutes ces dimensions qu'ell
soi culturell, qu'elle soit d'éducation
qu'elle soit et donc et ça ça doit être
100 % cohérent.
Ça existe des pays amis sur les chiquers
de la guerre économique, ça existe des
pays amis ?
Bien sûr que ça existe beaucoup des des
pays amis. Donnez-moi un pays amis de la
France.
Mais c'est faudrait déjà peut-être
préciser en effet la définition de de
pay de de PMI. Non mais je m'explique.
Vous vous êtes des partenaires et c'est
peut-être Non et c'est peut-être un
terme
les Russes qui parlent comme ça. Les
Russes disent oh on a des partenaires.
Non non non non c'est peut-être un terme
en effet plus juste. Il y a des
proximités évidemment fortes avec les
États enfin la France États-Unis. Il y a
des proximités évidemment fortes. Ce qui
veut pas dire le sujet n'est pas d'être
naïf. Il faut comprendre ce qui nous
unit. Il faut comprendre là où les
intérêts des pays divergent.
Je m'insurge beaucoup quand on parle
énormément de l'amitié franco-allemande.
Bon, je crois qu'à titre personnel,
c'est quelque chose qui me parle
profondément. Mais
parce que vous êtes alsacienne
aussi. Euh mais ce que je veux dire par
là, c'est que c'est évidemment important
de comprendre ce sur quoi on a des
sujets communs et ce sur quoi on a des
sujets mais c'est même pas divergent.
c'est sur lesquels on ne sera jamais
d'accord parce que l'Allemagne a
appliqué et et franchement qu'il emblâme
là-dessus appliquer une politique qui
est l'Allemagne d'abord et l'Europe
avait un intérêt parce que l'Allemagne
d'abord et c'est d'ailleurs il suffit de
reprendre les propos de la chancelère
qui sont d'ailleurs passés quasiment
inaperçus quand elle a dit ça il y a
quelques il y a quelques mois ce qui est
quelque chose qu'elle n'aurait pas dit
il y a quelques temps donc mais là c'est
même verbalisé pour ceux qui avaient pas
pas compris avant. Bon, mais c'est mais
c'est pas mais mais quelque part encore
une fois, est-ce qu'on va demander à un
pays de ne pas se mettre en avant
lui-même ? Enfin, il y a des il y a des
gens qui peuvent avoir le sens du
sacrifice libre à eux, mais on peut
respecter le fait qu'un pays se mette
plus en avant. Ce que nous on doit
faire, c'est d'être éminemment au
courant de nos propres intérêts, de ce
qui fait notre souveraineté
et des fondements de notre souveraineté
et ensuite après d'avoir une stratégie.
ce qui ce que moi je vois le plus dans
les pays que je peux je peux conseiller
et d'ailleurs j'insiste beaucoup moi sur
le fait de leur dire souveraineté c'est
soyez conscients de ce que vous faites
des exemples mais même des exemples
techniques quand vous signez un contrat
avec une entreprise d'un autre pays ou
avec un autre état puisque ça peut
arriver
renoncez-vous à votre souveraineté ou
pas cette question soyez très en
conscience c'est pas à moi qui se passe
une moyenne de votre pays de vous dire
si vous devez renoncer à votre
souveraineté ou pas. Enfin, je j'ai je
m'enmêle pas, mais je vous dis que si
vous faites ça, vous y renoncez. Est-ce
que c'est ce que vous voulez ? Bon, et
ces questions-là, elles sont éminemment
importantes parce que de temps en temps,
là aussi pareil, il y a des gens qui
prennent des décisions en se rendant pas
toujours compte à quel point ils peuvent
se mettre pied point liés avec certaines
autres parties. Alors, certains c'est un
cynisme parce que ben tout dans 4 ans,
dans 5 ans, j'en sais rien, je serai
plus là. Mais il y en a aussi qui n'ont
pas forcément toute la perception
de construction d'empire que certains
pays peuvent peuvent avoir. Prenez la
Chine
quand il déroule ce qui est je je le
simplifie à l'extrême mais c'est
vraiment pas rendre justice à énormément
de travail qu'ils ont mis derrière tout
ça.
Travailler en Chine ? Non, je veux pas
travailler en Chine. Mais la la
stratégie de la route de la soie, c'est
quand même c'est assez vulgaire de de
dire juste ça en une phrase vu tout ce
qu'il y a derrière derrière ça. C'est ça
que je veux dire. C'est il faut bon mais
en fait quand il quand il vous présente
ça en fait ils aimeraient bien voir de
l'autre côté bah nous c'est notre
stratégie de notre route de la soie nous
c'est ça. Bon et le vrai sujet c'est que
on n pas vraiment quelque chose
d'équivalent à leur opposer pas opposé
d' c'est pas le bon terme mais sur
lesquels on puisse discuter. Et donc
c'est ça le c'est ça le vrai sujet. Le
sujet, il est la vision, il est la
cohérence et il a le fait, il est le
fait de prendre des décisions à court,
moyen, long terme qui sont cohérentes.
Sinon, vous n'avez aucun résultat. Si
vous saupoudrez, si vous faites ça et en
même temps ça et en même temps ça et en
même temps ça, ça ne marche jamais. Ou
ça peut marcher de manière ponctuelle
parce que vous avez un coup de chance et
que tout d'un coup la conjoncture repart
pour tout le monde. Mais des ça ne
fonctionne sur le long terme jamais. et
les pays qui ont qui sont des ce qu'on
appelle des miracles ou des exemples ou
des parce que euh on adore on a adoré
trouver la geéorgie comme un exemple
puis après on a dit le Rwanda c'est
formidable. Enfin, il y a toutes il y a
toutes ces modes euh de pays qu'on prend
en modèle. Ce qu'ils ont en commun,
c'est d'avoir pendant un temps qui
n'était pas un mois mis en œuvre une
politique extrêmement cohérente et qui
de facto a produit des effets puisque
c'était tout ça était extrêmement
extrêmement logique. Et c'est ça le
sujet et ce dont on manque actuellement
de mon point de vue et c'est un
commentaire qui n'est pas un commentaire
français, c'est un commentaire global,
c'est de la cohérence. Et de manière
extrêmement ironique,
sur un sujet, Trump a fait preuve de
cohérence, c'était dans son débat avec
la Chine. Et c'est d'ailleurs
complètement ironique que ce que lui qui
est qui a l'incohérence qu'on connaît,
mais là-dessus l'a identifié, l'a
verbalisé
et a eu dans ses différentes actions
quelque chose d'assez cohérent. Mais
pourquoi ? Parce que selon lui, il en
allait des intérêts vitaux. des
États-Unis.
Macron, il est cohérent.
Macron Macron et sa cour,
ils sont cohérent.
Il y a il y a un quinquena qui est qui
est qui est particulier. Enfin, donc
laissons le sujet de la période Covid
maintenant parce que c'est c'est non
maintenant de de non, je veux dire de
côté pour regarder les sujets de de de
de cohérence. Mais on va le faire, si je
peux me permettre, on va le faire moins
corporate.
Non mais c'est pas du tout corporate.
C'est qu'on peut pas regarder des choses
qui n'ont qui peuvent pas se comparer
parce que dans ce cas-là, on n pas une
analyse qui est précise et c'est quand
même et c'est quand même ça ce qu'il
faut faire. Il y a dans le début du du
quinquena quelque chose de très assumé
qui est quelque chose de libéral.
Donc là-dessus, est-ce qu'il y a une
cohérence libérale ?
Oui. Enfin, je Non.
Est-ce que elle est adaptée avec les
fractures, les blessures
du pays ? Non. Enfin, et il y a pas
besoin
du mouvement des gilets jaunes pour le
savoir. Bon, donc
on en est là quand arrive la crise Covid
parce que c'est quand même ça la manière
dont les choses se passent. Et là, c'est
très intéressant parce que
vous avez des réactions de pays qui sont
complètement différentes. Et c'est là où
je trouve quelque part que ce qu'on fait
nous actuellement est intéressant parce
qu'on a pu voir comment les pays
réagissaient.
La réalité c'est que arrive donc ce
virus,
il y a la première partie qui consiste à
dire ce virus touche les autres mais ne
nous touche pas nous.
Au début, il y avait quand même et en
particulier côté côté Europe le fait de
penser que ça allait être l'équivalent
de certaines pandémie qui s'étaient
passé en Asie uniquement.
Et puis après évidemment les choses
arrivent. Ensuite, on se dit quand même
ces Italiens, quels idiots, nous on sait
faire mieux. Bon et ensuite après tout
se tout s'enchaîne. Et à partir de ce
moment-là où tout le monde voit qu'en
fait tout le monde va être touché,
il y a beaucoup de Ah mais qu'est-ce que
fait un tel ? Qu'est-ce que il y a
beaucoup de je en tout cas au niveau des
chefs d'état et en tout cas ceux avec
lesquels on travaille beaucoup de partag
d'information beaucoup de Mais au début
il y a un côté extrêmement tétanisé de
qu'est-ce que je fais ? Non mais
c'était un peu ça était un peu la
débacle c'était chacun son cul et dieu
pour tous. On vole les masques sur les
tarmaques d'aéroport on passe on passe
des lois en mode guerrier c'est-à-dire
l'importation l'exportation de produits
médicaux. Bon maintenant c'est terminé.
La solidarité européenne a volé en éclat
quand même.
Alors la réponse européenne à cette
crise là, il faut la distinguer aussi
pareil. La chose qui marche et
finalement le projet européen le plus
abouti qui est la BCE puisque puisque le
reste n'est pas aussi consolidé que ça.
La BCE est une entité. Donc ce qui
marche dans le sens qui est capable
d'agir vite et ça ils ont agi vite puis
après on peut débattre de est-ce qu'il
fallait faire ça pas faire ça ? comment
il faut le faire, ça c'est autre chose.
Eux agissent vite. Après derrière en
effet beaucoup de tergiversation et puis
tout simplement en fait il y a pas de
robe de la santé enfin c'était pas
quelque chose qui existait et il y a
certains certaines inefficiences dans le
système européen qui fait que bah oui,
on n'est pas capable de sortir telle et
telle chose rapidement. Bon et puis
progressivement on apprend on apprend
derrière. Mais en effet sur des
solidarités qui n'ont pas toujours
fonctionné comme elle devaiit, conférer
l'Italie qui s'est sentie euh plus
qu'abandonnée. Et puis euh on en a parlé
un peu mais pas tant que ça alors que
c'était une vraie réalité. Beaucoup de
maires italiens qui avaient enlevé à ce
moment-là le drapeau euh européen des
mairies hein. Ça c'est c'était quand
même une c'était quand même une réalité.
Bon mais donc une fois qu'on a dit ça,
vous êtes aux responsabilités, vous avez
cette pandémie à gérer. Et ben, il y a
eu des réactions très différentes que
que j'ai pu que j'ai pu voir. Il y a
certains pays qui ont dit on comprend
rien, on ne sait pas du tout
lesquels
ça peut être des pays des Ça peut être
des pays des balcons essentiellement qui
ont pu dire ça. Ça peut être certains
pays aussi du Moyen-Orient. Ça peut être
des pays africains. C'était pas vraiment
un continent. Il y a c'est vraiment
certains chefs d'état qui ont dit "Je ne
comprends pas." Enfin bon et en disant
ça disant il faut soutenir tout le monde
a eu le réflexe de dire je soutiens mon
économie voulant dire les individus et
les entreprises. Et il y a ceux qui ont
dit "Bon, comme on sait pas la durée de
la crise, on va prendre des mesures et
puis des mesures et des puis on va voir
après pour en fait tirer le fil.
On va s'agiter
non plus de dire on va affiner au fur et
à mesure" mais qui était dans l'idée
d'une parce que quand vous avez une
crise comme ça, vous avez trois phases.
Vous avez la phase de réaction, la phase
de transition et la phase de relance
après-drière. Et en fait, il faut juste
savoir dans quelle phase vous êtes et
bien gérer les choses. Que la phase, la
première phase soit une phase
extrêmement coûteuse, le fameux quil en
coûte ou d'autres gens utilisaient
d'autres formules. Nous sommes en
guerre.
Alors ça c'est autre chose, nous sommes
en guerre. Mais sur le quoi qu'il est en
coûte économique, tout le monde a
appliqué la même formule et quelque part
l'argent dépensé à ce moment-là, en tout
cas en France, mais dans d'autres pays
aussi l'a été au mieux qui devait être.
Enfin, il y a peut-être quelques petites
choses qu'on aurait pu corriger, mais é
mais ça les 10 15 % de dettes sur PIB,
encore une fois, si on considère que
c'est la grandeur qu' sont liés à ça,
peut-être 50 ans
non non pas pas sur cette phase là. Non,
c'est important sur c'est la toute toute
toute première phase. Après justement le
sujet c'est le reste. Le sujet c'est le
reste parce que cette phase- là, elle
est quasiment indiscutable. Et je je
parle pas de sujet sanitaire, je suis
pas compétente sur ces sujets-là. Je dis
en économie il y a il y a pas de il y a
pas de il y a il y a pas de
économique
renseignement économique
sur qu'est-ce que vous voulez savoir sur
renseignement économique ?
Bah tout
non sur sur le partage d'information il
y a pu y avoir des pays qui ont beaucoup
partagé des informations. Il y a pu y
avoir d'autres pays qui ont moins
partagé d'informations. Enfin je veux
dire là-dessus ça a été absolument euh
absolument variable.
Je vous trouve vraiment bienveillante
avec eux. Je je vais me faire l'avocat
du diable, d'accord ?
H
on prend notre cas parce que on peut en
parler, la France, grand pays, 5e ou 6e
puissance économique mondiale. Bon là,
on doit peut-être être 12e derrière le
Zimbabweé bientôt.
Non, le Zimbabweé, ils sont encore plus
bas. Ouais. Ouais. Ils ont ils ont
beaucoup de zéro sur le billet de
banque. Ouais, il faut dire merci à
certains banquiers d'ailleurs.
Non, ils ont surtout en fait c'est le
pays qui au monde a moins d'un jour de
réserve.
Oui.
Euh disponible.
C'est là où on mange les meilleures
brochettes de rat.
et on donc on est en France, on a une
kirelle
de fonctionnaires, que ce soit à
l'économie, au renseignement, sur le
terrain, on est blindé.
Ces gens-là se sont pris un camion dans
la tête qui est l'épidémie de Covid.
Mais on avait quand même des plans.
Avant, il y a des gens qui ont réfléchi,
qui ont fait des plans, des stratèges.
On est censé, on était censé avoir des
stocks de masques, on était censé avoir
des stocks d'antibio, des stocks de
machin. Là, on se retrouve en fait, la
mer se se retire et on voit que il y a
beaucoup de gens en short et qui se
nourrissaient sur la bête. Je vais pas
dire à rien faire. parce que ce serait
pas vrai, mais à brasser beaucoup de
vent pour pas grand-chose et surtout à
bénéficier d'une réputation
extraordinaire des 2000 ans de la
France.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait nous français ? On
va pas se comparer à d'autres pays parce
que on déteste se comparer au dernier de
la classe hein. On n'est pas dans les
balcons, on n'est pas dans les pays
arabes à monter sur des chameaux, on est
tranquille, d'accord ? On est chez nous
là hein, on a quand même des stratèges,
des mecs qui font du renseignement
économique, qui sont censés extrapoler
des situations, qui sont censés
extrapoler des modèles. On parle de quoi
là ? On parle de politique mal
conseillée. On parle simplement d'un
pays qui s'est laissé aller qui s'est
laissé aller au rond rond quotidien
bercé par un système éducatif où on ne
sélectionne que les ronds runners.
On parle, on parle.
Non mais on on il y a il y a beaucoup de
choses dans la dans dans vos propos. Ce
qui est clair c'est que il y a une éion
progressive de la situation en France
qui est très claire et qui date pas dès
1 an, 2 ans, 3 ans et cetera. C'est
c'est évident.
Alors on appelle ça un ronronnement. On
appelle ça ne pas se rendre compte de
certaines choses. Finalement c'est pas
c'est peu important comment on le nomme.
La réalité c'est qu'on est sur un
phénomène d'érosion. Et puis il y a de
temps en temps des choix qui sont faits
qui sont pas les bons tout simplement.
Enfin, faut aussi l'assumer.
Mais qui assume ?
Ben quelque part quand les gens sont pas
rélu. Ils sont pas réélus. Enfin, vous
voyez ce que je veux dire ? C'est dans
l'administration. Dans l'administration.
Oui, mais attendez, sur l'administration
c'est les les les choses sont pas les
choses sont pas si simples. C'est
est-ce qu'il faut leur donner est-ce
qu'il faut leur donner faim pour qu'ils
se réveillent ?
Mais c'est pas tant le sujet d'avoir
d'avoir faim ou pas faim. C'est quelque
je suis intiment convaincu que ce qu'il
faut c'est des grandes orientations qui
se déclinent et qu'à partir du moment où
vous avez la cohérence dont je parlais,
les choses après suivent derrière. Vous
avez énormément de de gens qui sont
passionnés par la France, par leur
métier, par et qui sont aussi énormément
vecteurs d'idées. Et le sujet, c'est de
temps en temps qu'on écoute pas les
remontées de terrain,
que de temps en temps on fait pas preuve
de bon sens, que on n pas de vision.
Donc quand vous accumulez les trois, ça
vous donne un truc un peu chaotique mais
sauf qu'il faut avoir le courage de dire
"OK là maintenant c'est pas on arrête
tout parce que il faut gérer." C'est ce
que je disais sur le fait de gérer
l'urgence mais il faut l'équipe du moyen
terme et l'équipe du long terme. Et
l'équipe du moyen terme c'est celle qui
après voit les différentes choses à
corriger ce qu'on disait sur l'éducation
parler de justice mais on pourrait
parler de tout ça et c'est ça ce qu'il
faut faire. C'est que comme ça que vous
remettez après les choses en en marche.
Mais vous ne pouvez le faire qu'à partir
du moment où vous remettez les priorité
de manière claire et aussi à partir du
moment où vous ne raisonnez plus avec
des avec des dogmes. Enfin, faut quand
même aussi se rappeler parce que là
maintenant les gens qui disent ça, enfin
moi je sais qu'il y a il y a quelques
années, je passais pour une pour une
folle, mais quand on disait sur les non
mais sur les 3 % enfin sur le 3 % sur
certaines mesures de rigueur et cetera
et le sujet n'est pas de mal gérer
l'État, au contraire, enfin vous êtes
élu donc en fait ça vous oblige en fait
de bien gérer de bien gérer l'État.
C'est juste un peu ce qu'on vous demande
de faire.
Et souvent gérer l'État a été vu,
compris ou traduit par je fais des
économies. Bon, s'il y a des dépenses
qui sont inutiles, évidemment qu'il faut
pas les faire. Mais le sujet Mais le
sujet n'est pas là. Le sujet c'est qu'on
raisonnait en
je vais faire pas mal de politiques
quand même d'austérité de coupe et
cetera dans un carcan le carcan des 3 %
qui dès le début était éminemment
questionnable parce que un chiffre comme
3 comme le 3 % il n'a mais aucun sens
mais aucun sens dans tous les sens
c'est-à-dire est-ce que un budget de
l'État doit avoir un déficit pour ses
affaires courantes j'entends de 3 Non,
c'est pas sain du tout. Ça veut juste
dire qu'il est pas bien géré. Mais
est-ce qu'un état qui investit doit se
limiter à 3 % ? Investir pour l'avenir,
hein, j'entends. Ben évidemment que non
parce que si vous financez de la
transition, qu'elle soit écologique,
qu'elle soit de société, enfin peu
importe, c'est c'est pas le sujet.
Évidemment que vous devez beaucoup plus
vous endetter. Et c'est pour ça que
j'insiste beaucoup et que j'essaie de
faire de la pédagogie autour de ce que
j'appelle la bonne et la mauvaise dette.
Parce que de la dette qui est juste en
effet des choses qu'on accumule
génération après génération parce qu'on
ne sait pas gérer les choses de manière
efficace, elle est inacceptable.
Donc la bonne dette, c'est le système de
soins, on l'a bien vu, on avait pas
d'assurance. C'est-à-dire que comme ils
ont réduit énormément le système de
soins depuis un certain nombre d'années
à cause ça coûte trop cher, c'est de la
mauvaise dette, là on se retrouve
bientôt à injecter 50 points de Paybe
pour pouvoir euh résister à à ce qui se
passe. En plus, on le fait à crédit.
Alors, c'est quoi la mauvaise dette ?
C'est la mauvaise dette allouée par
exemple au renseignements économiques
français qui font n'importe quoi. C'est
quoi ? C'est au doré qui qui dort sur ce
son passif. C'est quoi ? C'est ça de la
mauvaise dette.
Le le budget d'un état se fait avec des
recettes et des dépenses. Reis dans les
recettes, il y a de la fiscalité, il
peut y avoir des recettes de
privatisation quand c'est pertinent. Et
après évidemment
tout ça doit être doit être efficace en
ressources
et votre équilibre recette et et vos
dépenses doivent être équilibré le plus
équilibré possible. Ça veut pas dire que
vous pouvez pas être légèrement
déséquilibré. Et encore une fois, si
vous êtes déséquilibré parce que vous
investissez, il y a juste absolument
aucun problème. Si vous êtes
structurellement
en déficit sur des choses qui ne servent
à rien dans la vie des Français, ça ne
tourne pas. C'est ça ce que je qualifie
de mauvaise dettes parce que c'est de la
dette qui reste qui sera jamais absorbée
ou si elle est absorbée, elle est
absorbée parce que quelqu'un vous dira
que vous devez corriger ça et ça mènera
à une mesure d'austérité qui ira
pénaliser quelque chose d'extrêmement
utile. Donc il faut remettre les choses
à plat, regarder ce qui vraiment cette
cohérence, regarder ce qui est
important, regarder là où il faut faire
les dépenses, les faire ces dépenses,
enfin les faire vraiment effectivement,
massivement, enfin pas à moitié parce
qu'encore une fois si on les fait à
moitié ça ça ne produira pas de
résultat. Profiter de l'effet d'OBen
parce que de temps en temps on peut
aussi être aidé et avoir de la chance de
toba pour justement aller chercher cette
ressource. Mais le fait de s'endetter
plus nous oblige encore plus parce qu'on
sait que quelque part on crée enfin on a
plus de dettes et donc il est d'autant
plus important que la dette qu'on
utilise qu'on crée et cetera soit
utilisée à boncient mais le boncient il
y a tellement de moyens de boncient
enfin qui qui encore une fois transition
écologique et et et beaucoup d'autres et
beaucoup d'autres choses. Mais on a
cette chance que beaucoup de pays, je
dis on l'Europe généralement pas que la
France que beaucoup de pays nous envie.
Vous savez, moi j'ai certains de mes
pays africains qui disent on aimerait
bien que notre banque centrale puisse
fonctionner comme la vôtre enfin ou
avoir des marges de manœuvre comme ça et
qu'on puisse aussi emprunter parce qu'on
a vraiment des projets d'infrastructure.
Possible ça c'est pas possible. Il faut
pas que l'Afrique se développe quand
même. Vous n'y pensez pas. Soyez
réaliste. La
leur structurellement peut peut pas le
faire. Mais voyez ce que je veux dire.
Donc il y a pas le faire. parce qu'elle
est trop contrainte parce que le
non, il y a pas de parquis le tout
simplement les économies sont pas
suffisamment développé pour pouvoir le
faire et les besoins de l'Afrique qui
est sous-endetté en fait au fond et pas
surendetté et surtout sous-financé
doivent se faire avec un mélange et qui
doit être savamment dosé entre de
l'argent public. Pour moi, l'argent
public, c'est ça peut être de l'argent
d'institution multinationale de certains
pays et aussi du secteur privé. Et le
secteur privé ne n'investit aussi après,
ne vient derrière que quand il y a une
confiance, une stabilité et cetera. Mais
pardon,
c'est moi.
Non, je ce que je voulais dire par là,
c'est l'importance est vraiment la
cohérence de la dépense parce qu'il y a
rien de plus révoltant qu'une dépense
qui est forte, donc qui va peser sur les
épaules alors qu'elle n'est pas au
service
de la population du plus grand monde.
pas de résultat
mais c'est la même chose enfin parce que
le résultat c'est justement ce que vous
devez avoir par rapport aux gens dont
vous êtes censé être au service enfin
quand on est responsable d'un état et
nous modestement ce qu'on essaie de
faire à côté des chefs d'état c'est
d'être au service.
Avant de vous envoyer une question
internet vous êtes plutôt pour la
décroissance ou la croissance ?
Alors moi c'est c'est c'est des choses
et des grandeurs. C'est comme pour le
PIB. J'ai j'ai bon c'est des grandeurs
qui pour moi ve pas dire grand-chose.
Donc le PIB morile parce que ça veut
absolument rien dire. Et il y a juste
une chose, c'est pas parce que je suis
une femme que je dis ça, mais ça ne
prend enfin ça n'a pas historiquement
pris en compte le travail des femmes
sauf quand ça et c'était pratique de
prendre le travail des femmes. Bref,
enfin c'est un appart. Mais
ça c'est intéressant. Continuer.
Pourquoi c'était pratique de prendre le
travail des femmes ? Mais parce que ça
c'est des sujets de de révolution
industrielle en particulier et c'est
très bien raconté dans cet excellent
livre femme invisible. Euh et donc et
donc c'est très euh et c'est et c'est
c'est un c'est très intéressant quand
après il fallait qu'elle rentre à la
maison pour que les hommes descendent
dans la mine. Là par contre le travail,
il y avait pas de travail. Bon mais
parenthèse fermée, la croissance c'est
un peu la même chose. Ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que
on se gargarise de il faut x % de
croissance et c'est la croissance pour
la croissance. En fait, le sujet c'est
pas tant la croissance pour la
croissance, c'est la qualité de la
croissance qui compte. Et la qualité de
la croissance, dans la qualité, il y a
est-ce qu'elle est profitable au plus
grand nombre évidemment et puis il y a
aussi est-ce qu'elle est durable parce
que ça sert absolument à rien d'avoir 7
7 % de croissance une année si après
derrière c'est 2 % de croissance et
cetera. Et d'ailleurs les économies euh
africaines mais pas qu'elles enfin qui
étaient habitués à du 6 du 7 du 5 du 6
du 7 % de croissance et qui vont se
retrouver à des taux de croissance là de
1 2 enfin donc vraiment vont avoir
évidemment un effet ciseau important.
Donc c'est la qualité de la croissance.
Donc après décroissance croiss tout
simplement
un accroissement
des richesses pour pour la plus grand
nombre. avec et ce qui est le et donc
c'est pour ça que c'est pas de la
croissance en tant croissance.
Quelle richesse ?
J'y viens avec le seul débat qui vaut la
peine d'être discuté après celui de
quelles sont les priorités. L'autre
débat et qui est extrêmement
intéressant, c'est le débat de la
valeur. Qui doit avoir la valeur ?
Est-ce que c'est l'actionnaire ? Est-ce
que c'est l'employé ? Enfin, je dis ça
au sens au sens large ou est-ce que
c'est le consommateur ? Il est assez
juste que ce soit quand même réparti au
minimum de manière assez égale. Et on a
bien vu, c'est un peu la même chose
quandon parle d'érosion, quand on parle
de phénomène où les choses s'accumulent
et quelque chose qui s'accumule une
fois, c'est peut-être pas grave, mais
les strates après font justement ces
gros effets qu'il faut qu'après on est
obligé d'ajuster de manière de manière
forte. Il y a clairement eu un
déplacement d'une part importante de la
valeur vers les vers les actionnaires.
Et ça ça ce qui pose après d'autres
d'autres problèmes par rapport
évidemment aux employés, la question
revalorisation des salaires et cetera,
la question ne se ne se pose pas et
évidemment aussi par rapport sif si on
est dans une chaîne où il y a un
consommateur aussi par rapport au
consommateur parce qu'après évidemment
on dit mais il faut consommer bio, je
sais pas ce qu'on dit ce genre de chos
mais encore faut-il avoir l'argent pour
pouvoir consommer bio et évidemment
quelqu'un après qui si si ça coûte 1 € a
le choix entre quelque chose de sain.
Ouais. Ou de pas sain.
Je pense que tout le monde prend la
chose saine. Si après il y a des choses
qui sont pas saines, c'est peut-être
parce qu'il y a pas de le matraquage
publicitaire qui a eu derrière. Question
question d'internet. Black Rock qui qui
conseille l'Union européenne, on en
parle. Peut-elle nous expliquer le lien
étroit entre Black Rock et les banques
centrales BCE et Fed ?
Alors, c'est un c'est un cas en effet
extrêmement intéressant et qui est qui
est d'ailleurs plus large que le cas de
que le cas de de Black Rock.
Ce dont on parle là, c'est de fonds
d'investissement
et c'est aussi de fonds qui peuvent
avoir certaines activité de conseil.
Et ce dont on parle là, enfin ou le sens
de la de la question est de dire que
quelqu'un comme Black Rock, mais il y en
a d'autres peuvent être à la fois jugé
parti, c'est-à-dire investir dans
certaines certains produits ou voilà
actifs
et en même temps avoir accès
à par les activités de conseil ou autres
à de l'information privilégiée.
ou confidentiel ou
donc souvent la réponse quand on dit ça
comme ça est ah non mais il y a des ces
fameuses murailles de Chine Chinese
World et ce bon euh dont
qu'il faut prendre avec beaucoup de
calme sur leur sur leur existence réelle
ou pas. Mais c'est pas tant la question
là le sujet est même va même plus loin
que le que le début de la question. il
est-ce
que sur des choses qui sont stratégiques
là je parle de point de vue européen
est-ce que sur des choses qui sont
stratégique et la Grèce a eu aussi ce
sujet-l
étrangère c'est pas du tout péjoratif de
dire étranger c'est c'estàdire juste pas
du pays doit avoir accès à certaines
données
qui sont éminemment explosives
confidentielles et cetera
Alors après, on peut dire mais les gens
qui travaillent dans ces organisations
ont une éthique, j'en doute pas. Mais
sauf que la protection du pays selon moi
ou de l'Union européenne, peu importe à
quelle échelle on se met, devrait être
que des affaires entre européens restent
entre européens. Des affaires entre
Grecs, peu importe, restent entre Grecs
et cetera. Et donc ce que ce sujet euh
Black Rock qui d'ailleurs mériterait que
d'en parler beaucoup plus longuement
mais pose toutes ces question. Le sujet
de la souveraineté pose le sujet de des
conflits d'intérêt et pose aussi le fait
de après ils sont pas ils sont pas les
seuls mais le sujet du on va investir
dans ce qu'on appelle maintenant le
sustainable donc tout ce qui est durable
tout ce qui est bon.
Si vous avez été un très grand
investisseur dans le pétrole ou dans et
c'est pas pour diaboliser le pétrole ou
d'autres chose, c'est pas la question,
mais il faut après un peu de cohérence,
vous pouvez pas prêcher tout d'un coup
complètement le contraire le lendemain
et cetera. Et donc ce sujet-là pose
toutes ces questions, pose aussi le lien
en effet et et les conflit d'intérêt les
et les et les et justement les murailles
de Chine qui doivent exister, mais dans
lequel comme souvent quand il y a un
problème évidemment il y a le
responsable tout désigné mais il y a
aussi aux États ou l'Union européenne
autre à être extrêmement rigoureux et
non naïf par rapport à ça et à ne pas le
permettre.
Il y a il y a plus ce type de
comportement si on le permet pas. Donc
c'est toujours euh c'est toujours dans
les deux sens et là-dessus évidemment
nécessité d'aucune naïveté.
Comment elle s'appelle votre boîte déjà
? GSA
global. Oui, GSA.
Pourquoi maintenant le mot souveraineté
devient sale ? Pourquoi dès qu'on dit
souveraineté, souveraineté,
la boîte s'appelle le mot souveraineté à
l'intérieur.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi on peut plus parler
de souveraineté ?
Mais c'est on peut complètement parler
de souveraineté. Au contraire, je
s faire discrédité. En tout cas, moi
j'en parle et c'est et j'ai pas commencé
ça hier et je enfin alors peut-être
suis-je complètement discrédité mais
c'est c'est pas c'est pas mon sujet mais
évidemment que le mais attendez le sujet
de
souverisme
oui très bien mais c'est c'est un
concept enfin pourquoi pas mais attendez
un pays qui ne se préoccupe pas de sa
souveraineté
ben je suis pas très sûr de comprendre
ce que font les dirigeants. Donc après
il y a Non mais après il y a c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure, il y a
plusieurs réponses à ça. Il y a des gens
qui peuvent dire ma prior il y a
certains dirigeants africains qui
peuvent dire par exemple
non aussi mais mais je prenais par
exemple parce que je réfléchissais à la
Chine je parce que j'avais ça en tête.
Ils peuvent dire écoutez moi j'ai
vraiment besoin de ces 10 milliards de
prêt. Enfin une somme très importante
pour
éviter de perdre ma tête.
Alors il y a ça mais il y a aussi pour
développer mon pays. Tout n'est pas que
perdre ma tête. Donc pour développer
quand même c'est c'est l'argent est
tombé à flot quand même, c'était pour
éviter un grand basculement de la classe
politique quand même et puis toute
tendance confondu. Mais les laissons le
Covid 2 secondes parce que ce qui est
important c'est les tendances de fond
sur les infrastructures et vous pouvez
être un dirigeant qui vous dit quand
même cet argent OK je vais je le prends
parce que c'est c'est important et je
préfère développer mon pays que de me
poser vraiment la question la
souveraineté
si son peuple est d'accord enfin c'est
pas nous de de donner de de leçon mais
il est important de comprendre au moment
où il fait ça que oui il va avoir des
facto des relations avec la Chine ou
autre qui vont être un peu enfin c'est
pas la même chose de de voir zéro à
quelqu'un et lui devoir 10 milliards.
Bon donc c'est ça le sujet et donc un un
dirigeant qui se préoccupe pas de savoir
où est sa souveraineté, où est le
curseur de sa souveraineté, ce qui est
acceptable, ce qui est pas acceptable,
ce qu'il peut faire
rate une partie du sujet. Donc je sais
pas parler d'état sans parler de
souveraineté.
Est-ce que votre boîte c'est pas un peu
l'ubérisation d'un cabinet ministériel ?
C'est vache ça.
Non non, j'ai pas commencé à être vache.
Commencez par Donc est-ce que c'est pas
un peu l'ubérisation d'un cabinet
ministériel ? Parce que en gros les
cabinets ministériels, ça sélectionne à
peu près les mêmes les mêmes clones
que les vieux qui étaient là avant. Bon,
sensiblement euh c'est c'est c'est des
rondrunners euh qui travaillent
beaucoup. Mais est-ce que c'est pas un
peu ça votre boîte ? Parce que
moi je me dis en tant que français, il y
a une boîte qui va conseiller par
exemple mon état, mais est-ce que c'est
une boîte française ? Est-ce qu'il y a
des français à l'intérieur ? Est-ce que
j'ai pas déjà des organes censés
conseiller mon élite ? Mais mais
attendez euh c'est parce qu'en fait j'ai
pas pu dire ce que faisait aussi GSA
parce que une grandes parties de ce
qu'on fait c'est ça a toujours un volet
de formation. Donc je prends un exemple,
vous prenez aussi budget formation de
certainement pas non mais mais il y a
dans les missions qu'on peut faire par
exemple si on aide un pays à construire
à ploncer un bureau de la dette hein
l'équivalent de de l'agence France
Trésor ou pas d'ailleurs peu importe la
déclinaison locale. Bon ben il est
évident que le but c'est pas de leur
monter ça et après soit dire au revoir
parce que ça va pas forcément marcher.
petit suivi.
Euh non, c'est pas que c'est pas le
suivi, c'est que le monter ça veut dire
former les gens. Mais mais ça le dit
dans les deux sens. C'est-à-dire que
pour une mission comme ça, ça dépend, ça
peut mettre 1 an, 2 ans, 3 ans, ça ça
dépend de ce qu'il faut monter, hein.
Bon, mais si 10 ans plus tard, vous êtes
toujours en train de le faire, c'est que
vous êtes pas très efficace. Bon, donc
c'est
pas assez pédagogue.
Ça peut être ça, mais c'est vraiment que
vous êtes pas très bon. Bon, non, mais
tout ça tout ça pour tout ça pour dire
que euh il ça va de pair ce que l'on
peut monter et les missions qu'on peut
qu'on peut qu'on peut faire vont de pair
à chaque fois avec la transmission du
savoir. Donc en formant, c'est aussi
pour ça que on a euh on sponsorise la
chair sur la dette à science pot. C'est
donc c'est un acte fort de de faire ça.
Vous faites comme Coca-Cola, vous donnez
des sous pour avoir une influence sur
une université.
Ah non, pas vraiment. Je je fais exprès.
Non non mais non pas vraiment. C'est
décision première année de création de
GSA d'un budget vraiment éminemment
conséquent. Pourquoi ? Et complètement
assumé parce que je je voulais vraiment
faire ça. J'y tiens et on y consacre
tous dans la boîte beaucoup de temps.
Donc c'est pas juste de l'argent, c'est
beaucoup de temps, beaucoup de
structuration de ce qu'on fait. Avec un
comité scientifique, on a la chance de
réunir ceux que je considère et qui sont
objectivement les meilleurs experts sur
ces sujets-là. Pourquoi ? parce que la
dette est un sujet éminemment politique.
Euh c'est c'est disponible sur le site.
Il y a des Américains, il y a des il y a
des il y a des Italiens, il y a des il y
a un Suisse, il y a il y a il y a un
anglais, il y a c'est très c'est très
éclectique. La liste est longue. La
liste est longue.
Bien sûr. Bien sûr. Il est il a la
double nationalité aussi. Bien sûr. Non,
c'est évidemment. Et d'ailleurs, les
cours qu'on dispense sont des case
studies, donc des cas concrets qui sont
sur des pays. Et donc on en a deux
parents de 24 heures et puis après des
cas spécifiques qu'on regarde. Et donc
on a traité de la Grèce, on est en train
au début de l'année, on est en train de
traiter de l'Argentine, on a fait le
Liban ou on a fait le Liban entre les
deux et on a toute l'année 2021 est
consacrée à à l'Afrique. Et donc et on
on a on a des ces ces formations là. Et
donc pourquoi cette chair ? parce que la
dette est politique donc science pot
parce que justement on veut constituer
une espèce de librairie de tout ce qui a
peut être écrit aussi sur ces sujets qui
soient facilement accessible parce qu'on
veut pouvoir aussi continuer à écrire ce
qu'on pense et et avoir des débats comme
sur la dette odieuse et ça c'est
évidemment des choses qui nous tiennent
qui nous tiennent à cœur parce que un
citoyen doit être éclairé sur ce qu'est
la dette parce que ça l'engage un peu et
donc on considère que les étudiants
enfin on a un rôle aussi de pédagogie
par rapport à par rapport à ça parce
qu'aussi on fera venir et on a un
programme où certains fonctionnaires
d'autres pays pourront venir en
masterclass justement dans ces dans ces
cours là et cetera. Donc c'est une vraie
donc c'est une vraie vocation
pédagogique pensée et qui enfin progress
progressera évidemment au fil des au fil
des combien ça coûte
c'est c'est c'est plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros
plusieurs c'est en dessous de la dizaine
c'est c'est combien
peu importe une char d'université ça
coûte quelque chose si vous voulez avoir
les moyens pédagogiques de faire quelque
chose c'est ça ce qui nous importe
c'est des moyens moyens pédagogiques ou
des moyens d'influence ? Non, ça n'a
rien à voir avec des moyens d'affluence.
Est-ce que vous comprenez pourquoi je
pose cette questionlà ?
Je comprends pourquoi vous la posez,
mais comme moi je sais pourquoi je l'ai
fait, la réponse non seulement votre
question me jeune pas, mais ma réponse
est très immédiate.
C'est pour ça que vous êtes ici. Euh
question d'internet, que pensent-t-elle
du grand reset ?
Je suis pas je suis pas sûre d'en penser
quelque chose, très honnêtement
parce que déjà qu'est-ce que ça veut
vraiment dire ?
Euh
je je pense qu'on est
dans une ère
où il faut réellement tout repenser
parce que les mouvements, on l'a dit, il
y a eu un mouvement lent d'érosion, il y
a des mouvements d'accélération, tout
est en train de se chambouler. Euh tout
est en train d'être dans des choses
qu'on ne maîtrise pas, dans des domaines
qu'on ne maîtrise pas
et sur lesquels on n' pas de on n' pas
de référence et et et il faut savoir
comprendre les grands équilibres
et c'est pas simple de les comprendre et
il faut savoir trouver des solutions à
ces grands équilibres.
On fait beaucoup de travail et c'est un
sujet qui me passionne beaucoup qui est
le lien entre les diasporas
et les pays d'accueil d'origine pardon.
Et ce ce travail- làà est pour moi un
travail éminemment important de lien
entre les pays, de lien entre les
communautés et de circulation qui doit
être fluide entre les différents côtés
et où la diaspora d'un pays vivant
dans un autre pays doit être valorisé
pour sa double culture. C'est toujours
quelque chose qui moi m'a frappé que ce
soit jamais dit. Mais quand vous êtes
d'origine, j'en sais rien, sénégalaise,
béninoise, ce que vous voulez, vous avez
vous êtes déjà riche d'une double
culture. De temps en temps, nous on
n'est pas riche d'une double culture.
Donc, faut savoir reconnaître le ça et
c'est très important. Tout comme il faut
savoir garder le lien avec le pays
d'origine ou le pays euh même si c'est
d'origine de plusieurs générations parce
que il y a énormément de choses à faire
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
veulent rentrer après qui sont après des
cadres importants pour leur pays parce
qu'ils maintiennent des liens avec le
pays dans lequel ils ont pu habiter et
que il doit y avoir des mécanismes fort
puissants qui sont créés et que quelque
part on a de temps en temps une vision
de la coopération ou de lien entre pays
qui sont pas suffisamment fait autour de
ça. Et donc pourquoi je cite cet exemple
? Parce que il y a des tectoniques, des
plaques partout dans le monde où il faut
comprendre ce qui se passe. Là, ce que
ce qui ce qui est en train de se passer
là maintenant qui est complètement fou,
mais doit quand même nous interpeller.
La Chine a redémarré. Mais quand je dis
redémarrer, c'est pas redémarré
lentement. C'est c'est et en plein
régime. L'Inde bien sûr a des problèmes
mais globalement en Asie, je là je je
force le trait mais globalement en Asie,
ils ont redémarré là. Nous on est quand
même en train de se réeffondrer
aussi. C'est pas mal.
Si vous voulez, l'Afrique, il y a c'est
très très disparate parce que il y a
certains pays qui sont beaucoup plus en
difficulté que que d'autres et puis il y
en a certains qui au contraire c'est une
phase difficile mais quelque part vont
aller de vont aller de de l'avant.
Ils sont pas beaucoup plus résilients
par rapport à l'ensemble du monde
occidental ces pays-là. Je prends
l'exemple de Madagascar qui on peut être
associé à l'Afrique.
Si si on se tape une grosse crise
financière avec un un effondrement des
institutions, une débacle des banquiers,
des banquiers qui se font poursuivre
avec des fourches dans les rues.
Euh ouais, si on réinstalle la veuve,
place de la Bastille et la desbacle, eux
en fait, ils sont beaucoup plus
résilients que nous. Nous, on est tenu,
on a un système qui est pas du tout
résilient, on est on a une institution
qui est totalement euh viciée et avec
une inertie euh totale.
Ce qui est intéressant dans le cas de
Madagascar, mais c'est pas le seul pays.
Mais ce qui est intéressant et ce qui
est pas toujours connu, c'est qu'ils ont
il y a beaucoup de dysfonctionnement à
Madagascar et de choses qu'on pourrait
améliorer, mais ils ont quelque chose
qu'ils ont développé. D'ailleurs,
c'était un moment une coopération qui
s'était faite avec la avec la France.
Ils ont développé un marché intérieur
domestique fort et donc quelque part il
y a un côté
domestique développé qui fait que on
peut se gérer entre c'est les mêmes
sujets de qui détient la dette enfin qui
ont été discutés à mou reprise qui
détient la dette conférer le cas du
Japon conférer le cas de l'Italie qui
n'a quand nous on quand nous on est
la France c'est différent parce que nous
on a un peu près alors je vais pas
regarder le le dernier chiffre on est un
peu près 50 % détenu en France et 50 %
hors de France. Les Italiens, c'est
différent. Ils n'ont que 33 32, j'ai pas
regardé pareil le dernier chiffre de ce
mois-ci, 32, je crois, de mémoire qui
qui est voilà, c'est ça. Tout le reste
est en est en Italie. Ce qui peut vous
donner ce qui peut créer des risques si
vous ne savez pas les gérer, mais ce qui
peut vous donner des marges de manœuvre
évidemment supplémentaires, surtout
quand vous êtes des pays à forte
épargne, ce qui est euh ce qui est le
cas de de l'Italie. Bon, donc ce ce que
ce que je veux dire par là, c'est que on
est dans un monde et c'est c'est
important de le comprendre où et
l'Amérique latine malheureusement euh
auquel moi je suis très si attachée est
certainement perdu pour quelques années.
Là, ils ont vraiment ils ont vraiment
pour des raisons pour des raisons de
pandémie, il y a eu un recul extrêmement
extrêmement extrêmement fort. Mais donc
il y a des rythmes dans le monde qui
sont complètement différents.
Là on parle de l'économie. Il y a
évidemment des rythmes démographiques
qui sont pas les mêmes. C'est évidemment
important d'en tenir compte. Il y a des
rythmes aussi écologiques,
environnementaux bah qui sont là enfin
qui sont parce qu'avant on pouvait
penser que c'était de la
science-fiction.
C'est là, enfin c'est dans dans quelques
dans quelques années. Et donc tous ces
grands équilibres là, il faut déjà les
comprendre comme des éléments
d'environnement, de contexte,
de compréhension globale pour après les
prendre en compte dans les différentes
politiques qu'on remet en en œuvre. Et
c'est pas les juger, dire qu'ils sont
faux, dire avoir un ça c'est pas très
intéressant, c'est de regarder les
choses froidement telles qu'elles sont.
l'état du monde, qui nous on est au sein
de l'état du monde, c'estàd quelle est
notre propre situation et surtout où on
veut aller et donc après comment est-ce
qu'on y va ?
Et donc là, vous venez de me décrire en
fait votre
capacité d'anticipation dans votre
boîte, c'est vous faites des scénaris,
des scénarios, pardon, scénarial
et et vous faites des scénarios, vous
avez des actuaires qui travaillent chez
vous, vous avez des des gens comme ça,
vous avez des des gens du renseignement
économique, de l'intelligence
économique, vous avez des et comment
vous les choisissez ? Vous choisissez
vous piocher dans les cabinets
ministériels précédents, vous les
repérez dès le plus jeune âge à l'école.
On fait on fait un truc beaucoup plus
simple,
regarder le résultat.
On fait un truc beaucoup plus simple qui
est que on a beaucoup de chance d'avoir
un nombre de pays conséquent parce qu'on
travaille pour 20 états mais on est en
contact, je vais pas compter avec 30 40
peut-être même 50 et donc on a des
capteurs. Donc à partir du moment
quel type de capteur ? Ben, c'est parce
que vous parlez à un chef d'entreprise,
parce que vous parlez à un maire, parce
que vous parlez à un des dirigeants,
parce que enfin c'est évidemment quelque
chose
qu'on a oublié
qui se enf en tout cas moi c'est comme
ça que je travaille. Donc euh donc on
travaille ça, on comprend ça.
Avant évidemment, on allait sur place.
Bon, ça c'est évidemment plus compliqué
maintenant, mais on a ces capteurs là et
donc ça nous permet de valider ce que
nous on peut sentir par expérience. au
bout d'un moment, il faut quand même que
avoir fait pendant un nombre d'années
conséquent ce type de métier quand même,
on est un peu de un peu d'expérience,
sinon ça serait un peu problématique.
Donc vous sentez les tendances, ça c'est
ça c'est l'intuition mais vous les
vérifiez, vous alimentez, vous les
validez euh par des gens. C'est pour ça
qu'on a
j'aime pas beaucoup le mot expert, mais
on a un réseau de gens qui sont
extrêmement qualifiés comme dit hein,
qui sont chefs d'entreprise. Ça peut
être un médecin, ça peut être C'était
très intéressant. par exemple, moi je
m'étais pas du tout rendu compte de ça
en Argentine, j'avais pas du tout
réalisé à quel point il y avait un
retour massif des médecin argentin pour
de l'étranger pour essayer d'aider le le
pays et qu'en fait après le goulot
d'étranglement, alors ça on pouvait plus
s'en douter mais c'était la construction
des hôpitaux et et le fait que certains
n'étaient pas prêts mais comme aussi
beaucoup se sont mis à aider pour que
les les hôpitaux soient prêts. Mais
après le problème éventuellement qui
peut y avoir au sein du système de santé
argentin. Bon, vous pouvez bien sûr lire
tous les livres que vous voulez.
Plus efficace en tout cas de mon point
de vue de commencer à discuter avec des
gens qui sont réellement sur le terrain.
Donc voilà ce qu'on fait et pourquoi
est-ce qu'on en a besoin ? Parce que
vous pouvez pas sérieusement conseiller
un chef d'état et pas essayer de lui
dire voilà quelle est notre vision du
monde et c'est très prétentieux. quel
est ce que l'on comprend du monde et
voilà ce que l'on pense que vous devriez
euh euh
faire ou les décisions que vous devrez
prendre en connaissance de cause de tout
l'environnement.
C'est qui vos concurrents ? Ben
je suis pas sûr qu'on est vraiment des
concurrents. En fait, je
dit ils font pas ça.
Ah pas du tout. Non pas du tout. En fait
si vous voulez que en fait là quand je
dis pas de concurrent c'est parce qu'en
fait on a vraiment créé quelque chose
unique. C'est c'est pareil c'est
prétentieux. J'aime pas dire ça mais
c'est qui n'existe pas. Pourquoi ? Parce
que il y a certains volets qui sont des
choses que certaines peut-être banques
d'affaires peuvent faire quand il y a du
conseil sur de la dette. Il y a d'autres
gens qui font du conseil sur la dette.
Il y a des cabinets de consultants qui
peuvent aussi faire de l'aide sur de la
fiscalité ou des plans de développement
et cetera. Après, sur l'intelligence
économique, vous savez, nous c'est
plutôt quelque chose
l'économie de l'intelligence, c'est ça ?
Non non, mais c'est plutôt quelque chose
que nous on utilise dans nos prises de
décision. C'est pas quelque chose que
l'on vend, c'est pas du tout ça ce qu'on
fait. Mais par contre, ne pas savoir
dire à un dirigeant qui peut appeler, je
évidemment une des questions qu'on m'a
le plus fréquemment posé, enfin c'est
c'est extrêmement simple qui était
qu'est-ce que change une élection de de
Biden euh le cas échéant ? C'est
évidemment anticipation. euh sur alors
ça peut être des grands sujets
transversaux qui les leur importent ou
euh sur mon pays com comment tu ou mon
continent enfin comment tu vois les
choses ? Bon je considère que c'est
quand même notre métier de savoir
répondre à cette question. Bon donc et
pour moi c'est pas de l'intelligence
économique ou quoi que ce soit, c'est
tout simplement comprendre les relations
entre les deux pays, avoir évidemment le
dialogue qui va bien à Washington pour
savoir ce que peuvent penser telle ou
telle équipe. Enfin pour bon mais donc
c'est ça fait juste c'est une
conversation parmi je sais pas combien
de conversations mais auxquelles on doit
juste avoir la réponse. C'est la base le
socle de ce qu'on doit savoir quand on
nous pose la question.
Vous voulez pas lâcher votre boîte et et
vous lancer en politique ?
J'ai créé ma boîte. J'ai j'ai c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui me tient
beaucoup à cœur ce que je vais dire là.
Il y a 30
employés qui travaillent dans la boîte.
Il y a que ce que je disais ce réseau
une cinquantaine et on veut le faire
grossir. On a aussi beaucoup de
sous-traitants. C'est c'est normal,
c'est la vie d'une d'une boîte. Et j'ai
compté parce que je je regardais
évidemment beaucoup des mesures
gouvernementales et donc je me me suis
dit moi-même finalement de combien c'est
pas de famille. Eton responsable, mais
quand même, j'aime bien raisonner comme
ça. Et en fait, il y a quelque chose
comme à on va dire proche d'une
soixantaine euh où on a un impact fort
parce qu'évidemment un sous-traitant, il
ne travaille pas que pour vous. Enfin
bon, donc il faut
ça vous oblige quand même. J'ai lancé
j'ai lancé ce projet-là. Euh, on m'a
suivi, je commençais seul dans un bureau
de coworking. Euh, ils ont suivi, ils
ont su prendre le risque parce que enfin
c'est c'est bien de me trouver
sympathique et de se dire "On va faire
ça avec elle, mais enfin il y a des gens
qui l'ont fait euh et donc on est dans
quelque chose qui est durable, que je
veux faire grossir." Et je fais déjà en
fait auprès de mes dirigeants
un peu de politique avec eux à leur
service.
Comment va la France ?
Est-ce que vous voulez pas conseiller un
peu la France ? J'ai une règle j'ai une
règle d'or qui consiste à ne pas
conseiller mon propre pays. Euh
conjoint,
je je je une règle d'or. Non, j'insiste
vraiment de pas conseiller mon propre
pays tout simplement parce que il y a il
y a des choses qu'on fait et et et qu'on
et qu'on ne fait pas. Et ça enfin voilà.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait pas ? Ben
typiquement si vous êtes dans le secteur
privé, ce qui est mon cas, que vous
conseillez des États et encore une fois
vous savez 20 20 États, c'est beaucoup
hein, donc il faut vraiment et puis puis
on traite pas ça par-dessus la jambe.
Enfin, on est passionné, on est engagé
et cetera. Bon, évidemment, son propre
pays, on a encore un lien encore plus
particulier. Moi, je vois déjà la
passion que je mettais sur les sujets
grecs. Donc, j'imagine même pas la
passion que je mettrais pour les sujets
français. Mais dans ces cas-là, on n'est
pas dans le privé pour son propre pays.
Donc si on me pose une question, j'y
réponds. J'ai répondu d'ailleurs au
cours des de toute ma carrière, donc au
cours des 20 dernières années, on a de
temps en temps pu me poser des questions
sur telle ou telle chose technique. qui
non mais ça c'est pas très intéressant
des des gens de de ministère ou de enfin
des choses très techniques ponctuelles
intérieur intérieur défense
non pas du tout économie économie et des
choses sur la dette parce que c'est
connu comme une spécialité
ils le prennent comment on est obligé de
venir vous poser des questions
mais ils sont pas du tout obligés au
contraire non ça il faut pas le voir
comme ça c'est plutôt de dire est-ce que
tu as entendu quelque chose sûr ou
est-ce que enfin et moi je je réponds
toujours les non mais au contraire qu'il
part que ce soit partagé des compétences
enfin on peut que le saluer Mais je
considère que ce qui est demandé par son
propre pays, c'est un acte citoyen. Donc
ça n'a rien à voir avec ce que je fais.
Enfin, de toute façon, évidemment, je
mets mes connaissances au service de
mais ça n'a rien à voir avec une boîte
privée qui conseille des États, qui a
qui a décidé consciemment d'être
entreprise à mission parce que c'est nos
valeurs, parce que c'est parce que c'est
ce qu'on défend qui a tout le système de
fonctionnement autour du nombre de gens
dans les équipes. En fait, tout ce qu'on
a créé, mais ça c'est du privé pour des
États. Mais dans mon propre pays, je
suis citoyen. Donc c'est c'est
complètement différent.
Question internet. Selon elle, est-on au
bord d'une crise financière genre 2008
ou de ou 1929 ?
Alors, c'est une c'est une super
question. C'est ces crises en fait,
elles sont
toutes toutes différentes
et sans et sans quelque part parler de
toutes parce qu'elles sont parce que ça
serait trop long. Mais la crise de 2008
est essentiellement une crise
financière. Là, on est une crise qui est
dans une crise qui est liée à une
pandémie. Donc c'est des choses vraiment
différentes. C'est aussi pour ça que de
temps en temps les gens perdent
complètement leur repère parce qu'il y a
pas de précédent ou il y a pas de
référence qu'on peut utiliser.
Maintenant, est-ce que on peut arriver à
un moment avoir une crise financière ?
Ça serait possible essentiellement
autour de quoi ? Du fait que certaines
entreprises vont être fragilisées et on
le sait et elles sont moins fragilisées
en dette. Ça ça c'est au début c'était
une petite musique mais maintenant les
gens semblent en parler plus. qu'en fond
propre. Et donc le sujet c'est vraiment
ça, c'est vraiment l'accès au fond
propre. Et donc il peut y avoir
éventuellement des sujet de tension de
bilan des boîtes et des facto
éventuellement un risque au niveau
bancaire. Je crois que c'est que les
sujets sont assez anticipés par la
banque centrale. Euh d'ailleurs, je
crois que c'était hier ou avant-hier euh
quelqu'un en a en a parlé. Et donc il
faut mettre évidemment des niveaux de
vigilance forts. Mais là aussi pareil,
il faut pas parler de manière uniforme.
Si on prend le cas d'un pays qui met
cher la Grèce, les banques n'ont jamais
réellement été restructurées parce que
l'ironie de tout ça, c'est quand même
ça. Donc il est évident que le risque au
cas d'espèces là est encore plus grand
puisque de toute manière les choses
n'ont pas été n'ont pas été structurées.
Question internet. Est-il possible selon
elle d'avoir une banque véritablement
intrinsèquement éthique qui ne fasse pas
faillite par exemple qui n'investit pas
dans les énergies non renouvelable le
secteur de l'armement les entreprises
qui ne répondent pas à un certain
critères à certains critères sociaux
comme l'égalité homme-femme un bon
traitement des salariés
mais vous pouvez tout à fait avoir ça
mais vous savez il y a il y a quelque
chose qui s'en rapproche et qui est un
instrument formidable et que
heureusement on met beaucoup plus en
valeur aujourd'hui qui est la BPI
et qui euh est sur le coup quelque chose
dont les pays nous parlent énormément.
Donc, ils ont entendu, ils appellent ça
votre banque publique. Tout le monde n'a
pas le BPI en en tête, mais beaucoup des
pays nous disent "Ah, on voudrait
répliquer BPI, on voudrait quelque chose
qui est comme BPI." Donc, c'est quelque
chose qui est un modèle qui est
intéressant. Bien sûr que non seulement
c'est possible, mais il le faut. Et
après euh encore une fois, il est tout à
fait possible d'être de dégager un
profit
en respectant des critères éthiques.
C'est tout c'est absolument non
contradictoire. Ça demande d'avoir un
business plan, ça demande d'avoir une
charte, ça demande d'avoir tout
simplement les structures pour pour tout
ça et ça fonctionne. Après, il y a il y
a des sujets euh toujours d'exécution
quand on dit ce genre de choses.
Évidemment, l'égalité homme-femme très
important. Après, comment on le mesure ?
C'est toujours des choses qui sont
compliquées. Donc en fait le danger dans
c'est pas de la question mais dans la
question dont on ne parle pas c'est
moins les intentions parce que ça je
pense que vous trouverez beaucoup de
gens qui seront prêts à qu'après la
vérification
que c'est effectivement bien le cas. Et
on a vu récemment pas mal de
d'opérations qu'on appelait des des
obligations vertes ou des obligations
soutenables. Mais il faudra voir avec un
pot de recul si elles sont vraiment
dépensées dans ces dans ces
instruments-là. Et l'argent étant
fungible, le débat est plus compliqué.
Donc évidemment à cette question bien
sûr et oui, c'est possible. Attention à
l'exécution pour qu'on ait pas dévoyé
une belle idée.
Alors là, la question est un peu longue.
On va essayer quand même de la lire.
Euh qu'est-ce qu'elle pense de mettre
dans ses conseils ? De tenir compte de
la création monétaire colossale par la
dette et de toutes ces conséquences
délétaire et dramatique et responsable
des crises cycliques systémiques ?
Sinon, pourquoi ? C'est quoi cette
question ? Connaît-elle d'autres types
de création monétaire sans aucune de ces
conséquences dramatiques comme par
exemple la création monétaire libre
issue de la théorie relative de la
monnaie par dividende universel ? Il y
a-t-elle pensée ?
Alors donc dans cette questionlà, il y a
beaucoup de il y a en effet beaucoup de
beaucoup de points.
Ce qui est intéressant dans la question
et sans le relier à une marotte, mais
c'est en effet la création monétaire.
Pourquoi faire ? Enfin le comment bien
sûr, mais pourquoi faire ? Et le
pourquoi faire est évidemment
extrêmement important et doit avoir le
phénomène vertueux qu'on a dit,
c'est-à-dire la création monétaire ne
doit pas être pour des banques, pour la
plupart des la plupart des gens. Après,
comment est-ce qu'on crée de la monnaie
?
C'est ça dépend aussi de ça dépend de
beaucoup de choses. Enfin, ce que je
veux dire par là, c'est que c'est pas la
même chose. La réponse à la question
n'est pas la même si vous êtes dans une
zone, si vous êtes dans un pays
particulier ou pas. Évidemment, quand il
y a création de monnaie, il faut se
prémunir de sujets comme inflation et
autres et au-delà de ça, ce qui est
important, c'est oui, il faut avoir la
liberté d'une certaine création
monétaire quand elle est nécessaire.
Oui, il faut qu'elle soit maîtrisée,
qu'on en comprenne les effets
secondaires dont en particulier
inflation, ce qui est pas toujours le
cas. Et ensuite, après derrière, les
choses se régulent. Si c'est toujours la
même chose, vous en faites bon usage.
Tout le sujet est autour de l'usage.
Vous pouvez même vivre de manière
déséquilibrée un moment. Si par les
actions que vous avez prises quelques
années plus tard vous remettez à niveau
derrière. Vous
parlez pour vous là travailler dans la
banque d'affaires et
moi j'assume complètement ce que j'ai
fait et au contraire je déjà un je sais
pourquoi je l'ai fait puis qu'ils sont
pas des choses tellement intéressantes à
raconter mais la finance moi je savais
pas du tout ce que c'était. Moi je je je
fais HC comme ça vraiment par hasard
parce qu'une amie prépare HC et queon
était toutes les deux à Jucieux, on
faisait des maths, on se croise, elle me
dit qu'elle prépare ça et je me dis
tiens, je vais le faire avec elle. Bon
et après la finance est assez naturelle
pour quelqu'un qui a fait des maths.
Donc c'est comme ça que je me suis mis
de dedans. Et après la dette m'a
passionné parce que c'était le truc le
plus mat
parce que j'aime j'aime pas beaucoup
tout ce qui est un peu blabla et de
temps en temps l'action, les quit
history et cetera. pour moi, c'est du
blabla. Mais justement la dette, je
trouvais que c'était une matière
extrêmement rigoureuse en tous les cas
qu'on pouvait la pratiquer de manière
extrêmement rigoureuse. Donc c'est pour
ça que je me suis intéressée à ça. Après
le fait de travailler 10 ans chez les
man dans plusieurs pays, le fait d'avoir
vécu la faillite, je pense une
expérience qui enrichit quelqu'un. Le
fait d'avoir après pu travailler dans
une banque française est aussi quelque
chose de d'intéressant.
Laquelle ? chez Rothchield est aussi
quelque chose d'intéressant et qui est
une expérience évidemment qui enrichit,
c'est pendant les années où je travaille
chez Rotchill que je que je travaille
justement sur les sujets des États euh
au premier moment et c'est à ce
moment-là aussi où je j'ai l'honneur de
travailler travailler pour Tyras. Donc
voilà,
j'ai j'ai discuté avec des gens qui
avaient énormément de blé
euh bon pas suffisamment pour
déstabiliser un état et puis on a été
amené autour de la conversation avec un
petit peu de Gibolin. Vous connaissez le
Gibolin ?
Non.
Connaissez pas le Gibolin ? Il faudra
essayer ça. Je suis sûr que en Alsace,
ils ont du très très bon. Et c'est de la
goule. C'est c'est un truc
Ça doit être pour ça que
Ah ça délit les langues, hein. C'est
très efficace.
Ouais. surtout si on l'a fait un petit
peu entre provençal et et alsacienne un
petite cuillère d'huile d'olive juste
avant.
C'est vrai, c'est c'est c'est parfait.
C'est fantastique. C'est ça évite le
pain total en fait.
Ils me disent
"Écoute là, il y a deux choses à faire.
Il faut rester liquide
et ils s'attendent tous à une énorme
crise financière. Mais genre un truc pas
piquer des hanonsin.
Il faut rester liquide et surtout il
faut que c'est c'est il faut que ces
liquidités elle soit dans une banque qui
a l'habitude de gérer ce genre de
problème. Donc va chez Radhield.
C'est un bon conseil, c'est pas un bon
conseil. Ça ça témoigne de quoi ? D'une
angoisse d'une certaine élite ? Ces gens
sont très bien informés.
Non mais est ce que
on tr boî qui date de quelle année ?
On trahit qui est une boîte qui est plus
que plus que centenaire. Enfin la
famille
est est plus que plus que centenaire
dans les affaires.
Que dire de ce qui va se passer si ce
n'est parce que la réalité c'est que si
on va être modeste 2 secondes, personne
ne sait ce qui va se passer. On sait
déjà même pas prédire à 15 jours ce qui
va se passer. Donc de là après à faire
des prévisions projection, il faut quand
même rester extrêmement Vous
avez pas vu les forces les forces
françaises se déployer en en territoire
urbain récemment là.
Attendez, ce qui est entraînement, il
est il est évident
que on est dans une situation
économiquement compliquée, instable et
qu'il y a évidemment une grande
inquiétude
de chacun d'entre nous sur le jour
d'après. Enfin, c'est évident. Mais
quand je dis chacun d'entre nous, c'est
pas que les Français, enfin, c'est chez
tout le monde, sauf encore une fois,
comme je disais, en Chine où les choses
ont redémarré. Bon, donc qu'est-ce qui
va arriver de tout ça ? Quelles vont
être les conséquences et donc par
rapport à ça, si on parle de conseil
d'investissement déjà moi je je sais pas
en donner, c'est pas mon métier puis
puis on veut pas avoir la MF sur le dos.
Euh non mais c'est surtout que je t'ai
pas abandonné et vous savez moi je n'ai
jamais rien placé dans rien parce que
vos actifs vos actifs vous les stockez
dans quoi
justement moi je ne place rien dans rien
pour pour deux raisons très simples.
C'est comme je peux en effet être amené
à savoir des choses qui sont
confidentielles.
Je n'investis dans rien. J'ai fait ça
depuis que j'ai commencé à travailler
par éthique parce que au détour d'une
conversation, je peux comprendre quelque
chose même si c'est pas quelque chose
dans lequel on est officiellement
initié. Et donc par éthique tout
simplement, j'ai toujours eu absolument
tout en cash. Et quand un jour un
banquier m'a proposé un PEA, je dis bah
non, justement parce que peut-être qu'à
l'insu de il y aurait une action dont je
suis évidemment même si c'est vous qui
l'a géré dont je suis au courant et donc
je ne n'entre absolument pas là-dedans.
Donc pas bonne personne pour pour
conseiller conseiller quoi que ce soit.
Mais bien sûr que il y a un sujet de
quand il y a un sujet d'angoisse, il y a
un sujet d'épargne. Quand il y a un
sujet d'épargne, il a un sujet de on
essaie d'avoir l'épargne la plus
disponible parce que c'est ça ce qu'on
veut dire par liquidité possible bien
sûr. Enfin tout ça sont des juste des
phénomènes absolument réels de
d'anticipation. Et après où mettre son
épargne est évidemment quelque chose que
tout le monde sur lequel tout le monde
s'interroge. La le seul bon sens en
économie, en finance sur où est-ce qu'il
faut placer son argent pour peu c'est
d'essayer de le diversifier le plus
possible. C'est ce que les gens vous
disent de bon sens, c'est-à-dire de
potentiellement avoir un peu d'argent
auprès de telle banque et puis auprès
d'une autre banque et puis après d'une
autre banque. Enfin voilà. Est-ce que le
fond le fond de garantie des des dépôts
bancaires, vous y croyez ou est-ce que
c'est un éème bullshit des précédents
gouvernements et du gouvernement actuel
pour rassurer les Français ? Le fond de
garantie des dépôts banquiers en gros,
c'est si on se tape un gros carton,
c'est l'équivalent des masques pour le
Covid.
C'est ça.
Parce que en fait, on peut faire le
parallèle entre le stock de masque et le
fond de garantie des épau bancaires,
même si pour se muscler un petit peu le
le épaules, ils nous ont sorti, ne vous
inquiétez pas, on va pouvoir faire un
évet de levier pour lever plus au cas
où.
Le le sujet de Non, mais chacun prend à
sa propre théorie par rapport à ses à
ses à ses fonds.
Théorie. Oui. Oui. Parce que après il y
a des gens qui les jugent efficaces et
d'autres qui les jugent pas efficaces.
C'est ça que je ça que je veux dire par
là. Donc oui, je vois bien le sujet de
il y a un effet de levier et donc à
cause de ça, on peut lever plus. Ça ça
reste de la finance élémentaire. Le vrai
sujet c'est qu'à partir du moment où on
aborde ces sujets là, ça veut donc dire
que le sujet se pose
parce que sinon pourquoi l'aborder ? Et
donc c'est là où il faut être
extrêmement prudent parce qu'au moment
où on dit ça ou commence à regarder ça,
on crée de facto une inquiétude.
Donc là-dessus, enfin moi je sais que je
suis assez réservée par rapport à ce
genre de chos qui veut pas dire être
naïf, ce qui veut pas dire que c'est des
choses qui peuvent pas se passer. Euh
mais je dis juste que déjà dans l'acte,
il y a quelque chose qui peut être qui
qui peut être anxiogène.
Après, je dis aussi beaucoup que il y a
des Français bien sûr qui ont de
l'épargne. On est un une des un des
peuples qui a beaucoup de beaucoup
d'épargnes. Je veux aussi dire que
malheureusement, il y a quand même eu
aussi un appauvrissement d'une partie
forte de la population. Donc, il faut
aussi savoir de quelle épargne on parle.
Et ce que je veux dire par là est que
tout le monde n'a pas le luxe de
réellement penser à son épargne. Bon, je
dis ça pour dire quelque chose mais
après chacun a son sa théorie économique
ou ses ou ses prérogatives. Moi, il
m'intéresse beaucoup plus que dans
l'immédiat on puisse éventuellement
rebooster la consommation
et ou surtout qu'on se préoccupe de
sujets.
C'est les fameux sujets de moyen terme
de moyen de court moyen terme
typiquement comme le fait de dire quels
sont les gens qui potentiellement vont
se retrouver au chômage ? Peut-on les
former ? Peut-on anticiper ? Peut-on
faire qui peuvent se remettre sur le
marché du travail après derrière et
après surtout d'avoir une vraie
direction économique et stratégique qui
permettent d'amener le pays. Vous
parliez à un moment de dire 5 6e 7e 12e
puissance non 13 en avant. Et la
question n'est pas d'être un ou deux,
c'est pas le sujet, mais en tout cas en
avance de phase qui est la seule manière
après de créer suffisamment de richesse
pour tout le monde. Et pour moi, c'est
beaucoup plus prioritaire que de
s'occuper de les paris.
On a France de phase
Ouais.
Où il y a un changement de phase.
Est-ce que vous anticipez le changement
de phase ?
Non, mais c'est ça l'avance de phase
pour moi. L'avance de face, c'est la
nécessaire transition de vers quelque
chose d'autre. Enfin, c'est c'est comme
c'est d'ailleurs très dommage que par
exemple lors de l'élection
présidentielle d'ailleurs c'est aussi
dommage qu'on ait que des débats de
temps en temps lors des élections
présidentielles parce c'est des débats
qu'on devrait avoir tout le temps mais
certaines certains des points qui
étaient portés par un des candidats
autour des sujets de robot autour des
sujets de revenu universel était en fait
des choses extrêmement intéressantes en
terme de d'évolution des des sociétés et
c'est ce genre de choses auquel il faut
qu'on réfléchit. Donc on parle beaucoup
de transition écologique de bien sûr
mais après il il y a aussi des vraies
réalités du quotidien. Je prends un
exemple qui moi me touche
personnellement beaucoup celui des
caissières puisque tout le monde veut
trouver formidable le fait qu'on vous
remplace une caissière par je sais pas
quelle machine je suis pas je suis pas
très forte en technologie. Bon,
alors si on trouve à la caissière un
métier qui est mieux pour elle, qu'elle
est tout à fait volontaire à faire ça et
que comme la machine sait faire ce
qu'elle fait, ça lui permet d'avoir une
meilleure vie, je suis prête à en
discuter. Mais la machine pour la
machine alors que on lui supprime son
emploi et on sait pas vraiment pourquoi
on lui supprime son emploi parce que ma
petite personnelle, je préfère avoir un
contact humain euh quand quand je fais
mes courses. cours, je vais à la banque.
Oui, si vous voulez l'un ou l'autre,
mais c'est pas c'est surtout quand je
fais mes courses. Enfin, je ce que je
prends cet exemple là. C'està-dire c'est
typiquement ce genre de choix de société
qu'on doit poser parce que si la
caissière dit "Je veux faire autre
chose, je veux et il y a autre chose à
faire." Donc l'alternative n'est pas le
chômage, c'est ça mon point. et on dit
tous OK, les machines c'est bien, enfin
c'est justement c'est un vrai ça c'est
un choix de société et on doit après
financer le fait que on forme une
caissière à devenir je sais pas je sais
pas quel métier on pourrait au quel
métier on pourrait penser mais voilà le
genre de transition intéressante mais
c'est complètement différent de les
anticiper de les discuter de manière
complètement apaisée que de les subir
qui se terminent toujours en drame en
drame humain.
Pourquoi pas taxer le robot ? Mais par
mais oui, ça fait partie des idées mais
c'est c'est ça mon point, c'est c'est ça
doit faire partie des idées qu'on
regarde. C'est où le robot est-il enfin
nécessaire dans le sens utile au bien
commun et après faut-il le taxer pas le
taxer ? Enf en fonction de là où on l'a
mis. Enfin je parce que peut-être que
lui-même que je dis ce taxe lui-même,
vous voyez ce que je veux dire pas.
Peut-être que lui-même a une telle
utilité qu'en fait bah voilà, il y a pas
besoin de le taxer plus. Donc
on arrive bientôt à la fin de notre
interview. Un mot sur les cryptos.
C'est un sujet un peu compliqué
là-dessus parce que je suis peut-être un
peu un peu plus je suis partagée en fait
et j'ai évolué. Au début, j'étais
peut-être un peu vieux jeu parce que
j'aimais pas beaucoup ces ces monnaises
où je trouvais qu'il y avait beaucoup de
spéculations. Donc j'ai très rapidement
fermé la porte à ça. J'ai pas voulu
raisonner. Et puis après, il y a une un
usage, je dis pas qui m'a convaincu,
mais sur la blockchain qui m'a vraiment
perturbé en terme de positif qui est que
comme vous savez et pour moi c'est
quelque chose de très important, on ne
sait si aujourd'hui vous demandez quels
sont les détenteurs de dette française,
là maintenant vous vous me dites enfin
vous vous me dites pas à moi, enfin vous
dites à quelqu'un sortez-le. En fait, on
n pas la détention à l'eurprè donc on
aura des ordres de grandeur et cetera.
C'est pas ça mais on aura pas à
l'Europe. Et en fait des mécanismes de
blockchain et le trésor retrichien a
fait un essai autour de ça permet de
tracer et d'identifier
quels sont les détenteurs. Donc on se pr
ça sur le coup c'est c'est futuriste, ça
n'existe pas. Mais si par exemple
l'Autriche avait l'intégralité de sa
dette qui était avec ces mécanismes là,
et ben là sur le coup il serait capable
de répondre à la question à le à entre
guillemets le la monnaie près.
Moi, je considère que c'est un élément
de souveraineté extrêmement fort. Bon et
c'est ça qui me fait un peu regarder ça
ou évaluer ça de manière un tout petit
peu différente. Alors qu'avant, je
voyais ça comme de la spéculation pure
et quelque chose où j'étais moins moins
à l'aise.
Est-ce que vous avez trois bouquins à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Oui. Alors, il y en a un dont j'ai déjà
parlé mais je suis tellement fan que il
faut absolument qu' qu'il soit lu c'est
femmes invisibles. C'est absolument
exceptionnel. évidemment le Gréber sur
la dette he les 5000 ans. Euh et puis
alors il y en a un autre mais ça c'est
peut-être un peu plus personnel et
peut-être moins particulier mais je
trouve qu'il illustre beaucoup notre
époque. Toujours été une fan de Thomas
Man et les Boombroks qui sont vraiment
quand même le déclin d'une grande
famille bourgeoise européenne me semble
être assez adapté à l'époque. Enfin, je
trouve que c'est bien de le relire et
qu'on peut s'en imprégner, qu'on peut
tirer certaines leçons. Donc, c'est un
pavé et mais c'est Thomas Manit, ça se
lit très bien et je trouve que la
métaphore est pas mal.
Un dernier ?
Un dernier ? Ben alors, non mais il y en
a tellement. Il y en a tellement. Non,
ben il y a des il y a des très très bons
qui viennent de sortir de sortir là ou
d'autres à relire. Ce qu'a écrit Salomé
Verou est juste génial. Les sujets de
monnaie écologique de Nicolas Dufrain et
autres sont géniaux. Enfin, il y a
vraiment on a l'embarras du choix. Non,
au contraire. et au-delà des choix de
sur les bouquins. Ce qui est très
intéressant et important, c'est qu'il y
a énormément de pensées nouvelles en ce
moment et d'ailleurs, contrairement à ce
que là aussi on peut dire, d'auteurs
français ou de ou de ou de penseurs
français
et qui sont à la fois penseurs et aussi
à la fois font des enquêtes ou
travaillent comme peut travailler un
Christophe Gully sur des choses
extrêmement précis enfin particulières,
précises, cherché et cetera. Il y a une
richesse dans leur feedback et dans le
enfin plus qu'un feedback enfin dans les
écrits et dans leurs travaux et dans ce
qui le retranscrisent après
retranscrivve pardon après dans un but
de vulgarisation
extrêmement forte et ça je trouve que ça
vaut vraiment la peine de passer du
temps et de lire ça parce que c'est
particulièrement éclairant et là
malheureusement il y a vraiment
l'embarras du choix.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ?
Engagez-vous.
Pas d'autre, pas d'autres conseils.
Anne Lor qui échelle. Merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]